[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right what is going on
lords what is up what's up how's my
level
sounding design what's going on
i'm gonna um actually switch over
really quick till these guys get here
uh game awards i'm assuming
what's going on jose choice what's up
man
wow 22 am for you that's what's up thank
you super gab
i'm at work awesome you can't watch damn
damn
that sucks hopefully we get some
surprises
got a lot of uh i don't know who's
coming through today so it'll be an
interesting group i know um
addict should pull up a little late no
soft today the king should pull up a
little late
j doubles just share what's going on
chillin chillin
yeah man so we're just gonna work around
and see what's coming in i think that's
might pull up maybe a couple of people
might pull up
get a little live reaction what's going
on yeah why can't
you i need some i need some surprises
too man yeah i don't want to
i don't want to temper my expectations i
want my expectations to be high
but let me see man i mean i'm here for
all of all the foolishness and
game of the year who's going to be mad
who the gang don't win and all that good
stuff
dana rose what's up you gonna pretend to
work
all right don't die we got you we got
you and you're gonna wait for some
people to file in and see what's going
on
wait for some people
y'all just rocking with me today
rob c what's going on
[Music]
yeah if animal cro yo people sleep and
walk us i agree with you
animal crushing could mess around and be
like
the sleepwear the show okay
you know what i'm saying like that that
literally could happen
hey it's a powerful game it's gonna
listen people are gonna be very
emotionally upset with somebody's
you know some of these winners for some
of these categories
[Music]
oh man oh wow
king already hit me up showing me
[Music]
statues
what they dropped put me on put me on
cedric gage what's up bro chris what's
going on
dizzy what disney drop put me on i don't
even know
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all got my cyberpunk i
didn't really get a chance to probably
be so busy the plan is tonight
at least dive in a little five six hours
what got some stuff for the i think
lords gave me that neck
i have to do kryptonite what's going on
what's going on
all right so what i might do let's get
the ball rolling real quick
a little intro and get this roll and see
what's going on with participants why
they're not joining
us oh okay
okay okay okay my bad king is steady
waiting my bad
oh yeah yeah he right he right he right
okay what's up can you hear me
i see you there
[Music]
there you go okay there you go about
four yeah we
got my
[Music]
[Music]
for a second
[Music]
um
[Music]
mike again what's going on y'all just
working out the kinks y'all we're
utilizing some
new tech so we just want to work some
stuff out all right let's get the sound
going
from now all right there we go game
award sound
big little beat going all right so
they're good
what's up with this one
so if you hear anybody chomping in the
background
that's you that's not microsoft jumping
no i think sony's gonna have a hell of a
show this year yeah man they they should
they should
they should i'm predicting um metal gear
and silent hill
okay so you got you got some big
surprises going for sony camp
yeah um just the remakes though they're
gonna do uh
then they after seeing um demon souls
then the whole let's use stuff that we
got already
remix them and these dudes get crazy for
them they fall for the banana and tail
pipe all day
same old stuff with a d they give them
the same car engine
ridiculous with a different shell oh my
god yo this hugo look crazy
it's an exclusive and you know how the
exclusives
yo i've come to a theory microsoft has
made
game releases mundane
and what's right and and game pass like
because you know
when you got to go purchase a game you
got to scrounge up your bucks you got to
figure it out what you're gonna do so if
you really go ball out and you buy
four games dudes look over at you like
oh you're doing it doing it
yeah right but if you got game pass
you just go in and try four games this
is whatever it's like
i'm not in a restaurant buying single
meals like it's all inclusive
yeah i'm at the the the all-inclusive
getaway
and the dude is at the cluster you know
exclusive getaway there he got to
purchase
each item you know and all my stuff is
just paid for
so it's like monday like call of the
seat came up oh let me download that try
that
oh oh oh oh hell the king oh let me let
me download that let me try
let me partake in this particular you
know and these dudes gotta really make
life-and-death decisions on what they're
gonna get like i feel that
like should i buy demon souls or should
i buy mouse
i do like the way the web shooting is
going
[Music]
yeah okay you redo it about
i just need one person to join us i can
do this split jake but they ain't done
it yet so
otherwise we just put on the other thing
let's talk to the chat right quick man
what's going on chat that's just what's
going
on oh this is not a burger people
mm-hmm okay well it is cheating but it's
uh
um you don't like that you don't like
the fact that it tastes like meat
oh wow i'm just super chatty i'm bunny
what's going on oh man
let me see oh first off yeah shout out
all nyt music what's going on fire super
chat thank you brother what up brother
you already know
you know what i'm saying he didn't have
it what's going on then the man
cunningham he said i got that reference
king
you know what's in it that's what's up
that's what's up we popping the chat
back in the pop-up joint there we go i
can see it better
that's what's so good even lawrence
what's going on
mark is driving a new vehicle so you're
trying to see how yeah
right now i'm messing around with the
zoom giant you know so it's a little you
know technically getting working the
kicks out i'll be working out but let me
know how kings the levels is and
everything like that
rob c if i buy that pimp lords vanna
where you guys
sign it oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that would be like a show we go to a
show and we'll sign it you know what i'm
saying
dc want to see the initiative here yeah
stitch what up what's going on
i don't think you're gonna see the
initiative game he's say cog
really think he's silver circle yeah you
see why you ain't like my cosmic
background
son why are you here
let me show you i'll be seeing you now
[Music]
he liked me in the cosmos so he ain't
like me he picked me up
he ain't like me waving on him right
quick i had to wave him
he said you don't like our style you're
bad because i'm styling remember that
that got that boy duffed out yeah i did
that get him
yeah he did get him shut up he got that
thing that's a two-piece in the biscuit
no no no we gonna go back to the giant
yeah we working a kickstarter i just
need a third person to enter so we can
uh
showcase a feature we're trying to do
but uh i don't know where attic there i
don't saw
power cosmic what you know about that
theta rose what you know
other zig jumpers 30 seconds to the
microsoft show
you funny tony brian shout out to the
wolf right there tony bryant he said
destiny 260 frames
this is crazy game changing fun it's
funny how
sony didn't get a chance to sit at the
table they ain't got that rdnx too
they got to sit back they can't talk
about that one part over to hear what
the king say about sapphire oh
they're already jumping in already
what's up everyone sydney goodman here
coming to you live from los angeles
california
welcome to the game awards pre-show and
please allow me to be the first to thank
you for setting down
cyberpunk for a few hours as you can
probably tell
the game awards are going to look a
little different this year
our venue may be smaller but the show
itself is as gigantic as ever
the awards and world premieres won't be
changing except i guess the only people
clapping will be me and probably
a few crew members going remote this
year will bring us musical performances
from
london and tokyo and one positive of
tonight's mostly digital gathering is
we'll get to see more faces in the
talented teams behind
this year's outstanding nominated games
as for us
here in the pre-show we'll be spending
the remaining minutes before the game
awards kick off
with brand new trailers mercifully brief
integrated marketing and lynn will be
performing
a song from persona 5 strikers and best
of all
the big reason we're all here awards yes
our first category tonight is best score
and music oh that's one musical it's a
particularly strong contest this year
with
five standout nominees that could on
their own
represent the best of the generation
here
are the nominees for best score in music
do maternal final fantasy 7 remake
haiti and the will of the wisps
and the last of us part two and the
winner
is
final fantasy vii bono fantasy oh i
think we're adding something
okay you gotta stop blowing it up
what's up
of the year award sponsored by devolver
digital
and we're prepared for your help for
digital ceo
nina strutters
okay okay [ __ ] so yeah tonight we are
here to celebrate
this year's most memorable video games
let's not overlook the unrelenting hype
not for this but for next year's as yet
to be released games coming at you hot
from what many believe to be this
industry's most ridiculously
overrated publisher while most of these
games are months away from release
we at devolver digital are strong
proponents of awards
for award's sake and with that the
nominees
for the devolver digital 2021 game of
the year
are shadow warrior 3 by flying wild hog
olea by skeleton crew studio
card shark by nereo
weird west
[Music]
loop hero by developer four quarters
[Applause]
four quarters couldn't be here with us
this evening as lupero was unannounced
until well just now really
congratulations y'all put that baby up
remember your world scrolling forwards
and mystical items in the whole
[Music]
playstation
awards do our best to highlight new
games all sorts of shoppers from
aaa big shots like devolver to smaller
independent studios
our next world premiere is the debut of
a new game
from abu seb a young studio started in
new caledonia
enjoy
[Music]
california
all right hello hello all right brother
all right
[Music]
until it's completed
[Music]
[Music]
how do you guys hear me oh you're good
now there you go mr boom
boom world premiere
this next award category is for one of
gaming's
listen gentlemen congratulations 5k
thank you brother thank you
adventure game also leads to this
regularly being one of our most
competitive categories
incidentally for the past three years
the game award winner
for action adventure has gone on to win
here are the nominees for best action
action adventure
assassin's creed valhalla what we want
is our own ghost
marvel spiderman miles morales
the last of us
[Applause]
the game awards for choosing us as the
best action adventure game
i told you directors i told you they're
ready lots of us talk
back
hey listen what do you guys think of my
prediction master chief in smash today
master chief is going to be announced
for smash brothers they're announcing
things and i think
i was thinking it was going to be crazy
especially to our fans who
supported us and um yeah really helped
me well he's coming for he's coming
out
but first here's another trailer you
know what it's okay
because i don't know if you guys take a
chance to uh check out that waypoint
hopefully that's a challenge
i'm the ceo and creative director of my
games company called
beautiful berlin oh i see mario he's
drunk
that are especially important in
today's difficult times we can't wait to
share it with you
i thought you started later stay safe
you know normally it's a three-hour show
and i think because of the digital
situation it's four it's from seven to
eleven uh
seven eastern to eleven eastern which is
why i was like
dude because remember we were talking i
was like how do you cover this
did a prediction show it went pretty
well it was a good show had a lot of
people on head gas
from uh game on daylight
and um
[Music]
oh yeah this game doesn't look bad yeah
pad come on oh let's go let's go
let it go
[Music]
oh yeah only on the nintendo switch
[Music]
you gotta cover one eye to play it
you come with an ipad let's go do voices
photovoltaic that's right
call it a c and see a solid two sound
like only on nintendo switch
quantity
from focus home interactive here is
shady part of me
[Music]
there's 172 people here watching with us
if you're just joining us now
welcome we're in the middle of what has
turned out to be a
jam-packed pre-show for the game awards
we've just premiered two trailers back
to back
and now we'd like to take a moment to
announce
first is best family game a category
that did
a lot of heavy lifting this year
throughout the months of what seems like
an endless
touchdown when pools closed and chuck e
cheese went bankrupt
family games were always there somebody
said we're dabbling
i'm not seeing it animal crossing it was
animal crossing they were prizes
crash bandicoot i'm sending it to you
now it's about time
fall guys ultimate knockout mario kart
destiny better win the best communities
minecraft dungeons
and paper mario the origami thing
and the weather
and the winner is fall guys ultimately
you know what
you're right this thing is way behind
way behind bro i can't go
yeah you know what dude uh send me the
link for twitch if you don't mind
i got you brother i appreciate it
actually it's a ridiculous yeah
why is it so behind it's super behind
over there
phasma phobia one best debut game okay
i got you let me uh get back
oh yeah blam i got you bro
oh
the network just
and team ellie won the boat all you
tick-tockers get out there start talking
all are great
gaming communities see what their pick
is for 2020's game of the year
and the winner is go to sushima whoa
as for the game awards
that's the start till the end cherry
blossoms getting ready it's a start
that's the only thing they win
they setting it up early see they let
you get familiar with the blossoms
listen it's hard for me to be here's
where the tears start seven years
ago that my brother robin and i sat at
the ghost only when he's ready to the
ages of me and that's only gonna win the
night anyway today i am
so excited to start a new chapter of
mist with the release
of an entirely reconstructed vr version
that's available now
on the oculus quest platform oculus
quest we've got something specifically
for anyone who purchases
themed oculus okay so you got a guy
talking right now yeah
[Music]
and this show wants to turn up sharply
so i'm going to head to bed
you got you need to get in here man do
this late night stream with us
man it's like four o'clock in the
morning with duchess
that you ain't gonna miss anything right
now they're doing oculus rift stuff
welcome back to
the game awards pre-show for the first
time ever
i get to introduce musical right here
in the pre-show and i'm not sure there
could be anything better to jump
off with performing less surprises from
the persona 5 striker soundtrack
from tokyo japan here it
game of the year is not going to happen
you crazy
are you ready oh oh she's about to spend
her hottest 16.
sooner five music strikers
[Music]
[Music]
hey
let's go let's go let's go let's go
[Music]
[Music]
16.
[Music]
[Music]
to this do you get crazy pro bowl like
some of those
i still dance you know in the kitchen to
the persona yo
i said time yo still you stupid
[Music]
button
work he said this is that lit coffee
shop music
yo have a dude there with his hat on and
smack the cookie off his head
yo
everybody with their onesies on put your
hands up
you gotta smell me and some clogs
[Music]
[Music]
this is the game they purchased for two
years and nobody was crying about it
you could tell by all the orbs yo the
wildlife gamer said you know this
awesome he said you can tell the ssd
power with all the circles that came up
this is on xbox one as well sir so oh
slander is
oh okay i'm kind of digging it let's go
i have a white music taster i hear you
me too but i don't plan to get jiggy
with you
your living face and how is this gaming
[Music]
[Music]
that's not my competition
no
so listen king i'll see you tomorrow
morning hello brother death stringer
with uh singer uh we'll talk soon and
obviously in dutch we'll be talking next
week
people see your face let me see your
face tell them where you can find the
world
of gaming and you can find me tomorrow
without honoring esports
on youtube who despite everything guess
what you're probably not getting a
notification
entertainment yeah yo make sure
community time yeah
make sure you're not getting me get all
his notifications y'all
league of legends
league of legends damn right yeah i'll
take that
let's go for best esports coach the
nominees okay i know this one as well
grabs nope rambo yep zepha
and yeah and the winner
is zonic
okay okay whatever yeah
all right this one's speaker legends
championship 2020.
he looked the sonic name world
championship
[Music]
good for best esports host the nominees
are
dash overwatch
the nominees are dallas empire all right
damn on gaming gt sports
san francisco and tv i'm going with
shock because they've died with another
winner
g2 g2 esports yes
okay congratulations to all of the
winners
and now hey man i enjoy esports esports
athletes
here's the host of espn's first take and
the new espn plus show
stephen stephen yo we leveled up out
here
i know what y'all are thinking did they
just bring stephen a smith to the game
in the stream where you go into the
bathroom
they're doing their thing when every
major sports league in the nation
hey esports just kept it he said let me
tell you right now mean gene
all of these things without questions
show maker canyon
shots
so this big gaming is doing well this is
a good look
that dude right there a lethal enforcer
yeah you can tell he's straight killer
yeah he'll be like
no smoke with him in that game whatever
game he played to the store to get that
watermelon
told you to throw the fight
do it yeah the open world they got
skyrim type gloria chance
i mean oh yo these dragon mechanics yeah
this is the open mmo i need this game in
my life
what's bad y'all
yes
it means i'm about to sign off send it
over to jeff
look forward to your performances from
eddie better and the london
orchestra will be playing the
traditional game of the year medley as
well as a special surprise
i love all right so that comes in
february okay my february's gone
dedicated to that
too not that already
you killed the east category this is
sydney goodman
while you're on the other side of the
map
yeah if you stack three on top of each
other and hope one fandom
oh no we got the kicks yo the game
awards
this year of course will be a little bit
different uh it's been a tough year for
everyone i know and
normally with the holiday season we'd
all be gathering with our friends and
family and
i know that can't happen for all of us
but tonight we can
gather here and connect around games
something that we all love games connect
us
and i'm here in los angeles whether
you're watching live right now
in china early in the morning in europe
america
my native canada wherever you are uh
even in
india this year we're all over the globe
we are coming together tonight
to celebrate our love of videos now to
keep everyone safe tonight
nominees are going to be joining us live
via
tonight as we get through all the awards
live in the show
we're going gonna be joined also by some
very special guests look at all the
people though that's what's up
i cannot wait to leave
washington the swedish chefs reggie
make sure you have on your team we also
have a very special performance by eddie
vetter
from pearl jam uh he will be in seattle
and the london philharmonic orchestra
from abbey road studios in london
conducted by lauren balfe it is going to
be an amazing show and as always
we've got the awards got the first ones
we've got new game announcements
all of the things that make the game
awards special will be here
in fact that's right if the entire
industry
comes together tonight to celebrate
games
everyone is here shout out to me or at
least i thought everyone was here
it does sound like we're still expecting
someone else
to arrive uh-oh
oh smash he said on silent hill
he made unsilent mountain so who is it
who's the character they're adding
[Music]
oh those are the hands that come down to
beat people up
let's get it the best villain in final
fantasy
get yourself up let's get it
let's get it let's get it they better
have a song though they better have a
song i want it where they spit his balls
let's get it
it's across the whole boss
[Music]
[Music]
what
oh it's graphic this is not for the kids
this song is so good
oh he stuck the knife in mario
kart ain't got no dlc squidly ain't got
no deal
they know what they need to know what
bag they need they know what final
fantasy they gonna go to
they know what it is
oh man what pure fire it looked like
nintendo was winning
so far nintendo is winning the show
oh he goes garbo it's over
[Music]
this show
joining us now live on zoom it's brie
larson
hey bray hello
tonight i am honored to present the
award for best performance
among the nominees is an inclusive group
of talented actors filling vastly
different roles
and games oh yes captain marvel however
these artists are nominated tonight for
what they share in common
word clear dedication to their craft and
an extraordinary
ability to bring humanity and empathy to
their roles
here are the nominees for best
performance
my toe for stuff they wouldn't release
240 height 240.
that's nice we've been doing it on
twitch the whole time
let's try to switch it up they know what
it is hit the like button
thank you thank you for that get on
twitch with us thank you
thank you i appreciate it yeah we are
here goes to
laura bailey abby did it
[Applause]
oh wow um wow
uh i i told you guys
i told you what i meant
yes yeah i fell in love with joel and
ellie
so it is no surprise to me but i love it
uh abby's role within this story has
been met with such
uh passionate responses
but um yeah she got a lot of abuse for
that you can tell she about to cry yeah
she went through a lot
such a fantastically challenging
character
don't make me proud to find
forgiveness and empathy is something
that i'll be eternally grateful for
um oh man i told the team on the day
that i finished filming
that what i wanted more than anything
was for my performance to
yes tell the truth woman performance
that honored the impact that the
original game had on
exactly how i feel about that this award
means so much
um thank you to neil and tally and the
entire team for giving me the
opportunity and for
all of the support and the guidance
along the way um
patrick and ian and grace
of us
would not have been as impactful without
you by my side um
she was the best
through our i don't know decades her
performance was phenomenal
we've been allies we've been enemies and
we've been everything in between
uh and every single time i work with you
i come in i would like to see
like a behind the scenes when they're
doing the voice acting
yo you're joining the jump shadow
pharrell who i am green out the box
took his clothes
[Music]
your strength and your power and your
vulnerability and your performance left
me speechless
um i love you marry me
to my husband travis who spent countless
hours just listening
he's giving up two things i'm gonna kick
i'm gonna sign
the leadership obviously to everyone who
voted thank you for your support
and for your love and for your passion
and for
allowing yourself to go on this journey
with abby and with me
thank you
congratulations laura i think i heard
imessages coming in for people
congratulations that was going on it's
uh
so great to have everyone here
celebrating an amazing year for games
all right we are streaming on every
platform tonight
including twitch where we have drops for
among us and fortnite who both have
world premieres
coming up later in the show and
throughout the night we will also be
interactive on twitch you can predict
who you think
will win using a twitch extension first
up best ongoing games so go and vote now
lock in your predictions all right well
even with everything going on it's been
one of those special years that sees the
launch of new next-gen consoles and with
that
brings a whole new generation of games
tonight we are honored to have
one team a new team of veterans reveal
the very first details about their
ambitious and exciting new project
right here at the game awards enjoy
[Music]
pretty much since the day i started
there's been a really clear
player fantasy i think the thing that
makes it different from a lot of
first-person games is
it's not just about shooting eco sci-fi
is a term that we use
future fiction but from an ecological
focus there's been this ecological
photograph corporations came in oh it's
attic
oh my god on the surface everything's
added you didn't you gave me
everything's pretty great we're still
early in development
but we're really excited with where
things are going i wanted to share a
cinematic piece that helps set the tone
for our world
attic can you hear me king can you hear
me can anyone hear me i can hear you i
hear you
initiative let's go hey can you hear me
yeah yeah sorry yeah he kicked me out
cause he logged him with the damn iron
cow
and i'm like what is going on i remember
when everything changed
oh god
[Applause]
what is this the initiatives game and we
welcome them
yeah the initiatives
whatever but the laws of nature aren't
this an rpg what is this
we need to know what they're hiding
[Music]
what is this so i don't care if there's
a snowman
for that tell me the game
[Music]
cyberpunk did you find the answers you
were looking for
agent dark oh go ahead
hold up
oh guys this is what i wanted to be it
is it
it's what i wanted to be it
is over it is all gold
it is wonderful let's go it is
over perfect oh
that's a classic bro it's a classic
that was pretty cool where are you guys
watching this you guys are waiting
twitch
i'm watching i'm watching it on home
screen
i know i know you're doing
nice crazy still wanted to scream out
the name but i was like i don't want to
spoil it
wow oh
jumped right up in your boy face worms
all over wait this look like
oh they just oh
oh yeah four people i've been dying for
left for dead a new one please oh god
please it's been a while
yeah molotov yes oh god please yes
please let it be
i would love this xbox only
why i gotta
oh the tank
yep
yeah it's definitely that producer
you're definitely left with a center
[Applause]
no back for blood it's probably from the
people that made love for that
back for blood and i'm now joined by
chris ashton of turtle rock studios uh
this is
pretty exciting for all of us left 4
dead fans of course uh you guys are
known for all the amazing words
and now you're
and bigger right we wanted to have more
playable characters
more story uh but we also wanted to have
a bigger variety
of zombies to fight right but also we
wanted to go bigger
so now we've got 20 foot tall
zombies definitely
you know the help of your friends in
order to defeat picked up by somebody
else all right well it's great to have
this game announced but
it sounds like because they did the
aliens
oh yeah
is king right so let's see some of that
okay here we go here's the
gameplay reveal of back for blood wow
that's right let's get rid of this this
this cgi stop wasting money on cgi and
just make the games out
yeah let's see some of that let's see
what we play
let's go i'm about there
next [ __ ] toilet seats you see that
dutch
up against their wall this look just
like left today
oh this is what i'm talking about
yeah i'm about all of this this might
get me to break my game fast
you might break the road no i'm i break
the rule for this
the gun sounds nice the muzzle flash you
see
[Laughter]
no you better stop worrying about that
one armed man and started running
this is hard to do
there you go back for blood june next
year
alpha next week crazy all right very
exciting well tonight we're celebrating
games and we've got
awesome discounts on many of tonight's
nominees
we also have the game awards festival a
chance to play upcoming games like
little nightmares too
and some of the games are also available
instantly with geforce
now so make sure to check that out you
can stream on any device with no
downloads on geforce now well we also
have a lot of great stuff coming up
we'll have performances from the london
philharmonic orchestra
and eddie better but right now two years
ago we announced at the game awards
scavengers from midwinter entertainment
everyone has been wondering when they'll
get to play it for news on that let's
hear from mid winners
josh homes you know
thanks jeff i do have a really exciting
update for you perfect dark person
i just want to thank the many thousands
of players who have been testing the
game with us over the past
i was not listening to the world
that's like you got to give me something
that's why i'm happy no but you know
what
that's your joint that you were talking
about if you wanted that single player
yeah well you don't know what i want to
do but that's how i still want to
reserve judgment on that
you'll face off against many others
there are countless strategies and
powers to success
it's too much stuff right now too many
games
no well i'm waiting for that too but
i'm waiting for our dna so there you
have it oh you wait for the past
scavengers starts right now if you're
part of our community
you can play with your existing steam
key but we're awesome
we got 273 in here let's hit that like
button and share it out to people
go to places scavengers.com sign up for
free
and we'll see you in the game
let's see here it goes regal
that's single digits this looks familiar
oh is this that one game
yeah yeah this looks familiar
[Music]
boy it doesn't look good
halloween valhallas jesus
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
too big we gotta get them
[Music]
they got the hand-me-down of the aria
get rid of me
anyways instagram awards have teamed up
for
six new year's eve there you go
i played with them yesterday at home and
posted to the game awards profile
check it out you can transport yourself
to final fantasy
train station transform into the doom
slayer
dom the mask of the ghost of sushima
sneak through the last of us
or even become zagreus from hades to
create your own
just head over to the game awards on
instagram
icon and share to instagram reels and
i'll be back later to show off some of
your beautiful creations
really oh
[Music]
oh let's go oh it's going down
download it's going down
i'm ready okay so god
oh my god that looks so bad oh that car
is definitely a
a go-getter december available free
so so wait a second is where where where
do i get to play forza horizon 4
where's what console is that game
available
ongoing game award in the twitch
community
let's find out the twitch community is
right um we're going to present the best
ongoing game
which recognizes five outstanding titles
that continue to deliver
here are the nominees
no man's got a shot
the game award goes to no man's sky
[Applause]
look at your man look at your name you
got the bottle you said whoa
i was not expecting that no didn't i
have no man's [ __ ]
oh wait he had no idea
[Music]
ongoing game
and it's the ultimate redemption story
as a death said they ran off with the
bag and first
yeah they ran off with your bag in the
first place then they received an award
i mean
they didn't run off with the money y'all
just had high expectations for wii
consoles oh my god
you definitely riding off with the money
he was sitting right there drinking a
bit he
run no place how do you like to do from
um
the thing from dead space is a lot
longer
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god butt head is on you what is
this
oh they got black they get 12 black
[Laughter]
this is
we got 302 in the chat let's hit the uh
like button
like follow and subscribe let's share
that out right distance studios never
heard of them
that looked interesting yeah look
something like something in game pass
let's get it squirrel come in
i'm feeling some dead space vibes and
there's little wonder why you know him
from his work on dead space and call of
duty here's the ceo of striking distance
studios
glenn schofield hey glenn yeah let's
talk to him
hey thanks jeff well the christmas
protocol has been in development for uh
over a year and a half with a team of
well over 100 people on it okay
it's a single player third person story
single player third person
did you hear that this is what we want
from the games that's what god wants
callisto
single player triple a third-party
cinematic experience that's a
new piece console how wonderful
we're so excited to be able to show it
here tonight xbox games
i hear that awesome thank you very much
we're looking forward to hearing more
about that
next year all right announced back in
july warhammer 45 dark
side is a four-player co-op game fat
shark the developers behind warhammer
vermintide 2.
well tonight they're sharing a first
look at the gameplay check this out i
actually want to play this
so i'm done it's by the makers of dead
space so it can't be too bad
i want to see how this plays though
that's the side of my players
before
okay okay
next generation is looking fabulous
[Applause]
now it is time to recognize some other
winners the category of best art
direction
the nominees are final fantasy vii
remake
ghost of schemux hades you know if
you're playing
where to go you gotta go across the
street
and the game award goes to ghost of
toshima well let's drop it
theory that's two let's get it for best
action game the nominees are i'm wearing
foreign
streets of rage 4. and the winner is
actually hades wow
in the category of best look how quick
they're going through the actual awards
alex marvel's iron man vr star wars
squadrons
and the walking dead saints and sinners
the game award goes to
half-life alex congratulations to val
for best sports racing games those
nominees are this is no full-time
f1 2012. nba 2k
21 f1 tony hawkins
and the game award goes to tony hawk's
pro speeder 1-2
and for the most anticipated voted on on
twitter this year the nominees are
elderly i voted haloween god of war
sequel
halo infinite horizon forbidden west
resident evil village and the legend of
zelda breath of the wild
sequel i'm saying and your most
anticipated game
is elden rainbow congratulations
this next game comes from the creators
of gone home in tacoma the fulbright
company and annapurna interactive
present
one part road trip one part mystery with
two familiar voices
i'm sure it's gonna be cool
world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
my name is testifying for me and the
world is passing me by
yeah i guess as i get a little older i'm
starting to feel how things
change they decline and
go away that's how it was with my
grandma
i loved her so much i thought i knew her
better than anyone
but looking through her old things we
found
hints of something she never told us
about let me know
a man
burglary ring some sort of
lost fortune we can't ask her about
these things anymore so
we have to go looking for the answers
ourselves
[Music]
almost gonna be a firewatch fox too
open roads
[Music]
interesting
thank you brother i appreciate it man
you just say once again this year we're
excited to share some stories about
people around the world who are making a
positive impact on the gaming community
these are our global gaming citizens in
partnership with facebook gaming
our first honoree tonight is latinx in
gaming
check out this important story
[Music]
when i was starting in the games
industry as a latinx person
i felt quite invisible it still feels
like i'm the odd one out
i felt alone i was often the only
woman and the only latina woman in the
room i think about
how hard it was for me to get where i am
today
and i don't want anyone to go through
that anymore
and welcome to latinx in gaming our
content
alex our voices linux and gaming we
actually do a lot of following a group
of people
that are dedicated to supporting other
people
we've just grown from a really small
group
into thousands this was no longer just
about game developers
this is about streamers and students and
journalists and marketing
to chase it it's a really beautiful
thing i'm trying not to cry i was this
close
with your camera where am i where my
camera at i had to use my own everyone
my name is anna dolan i am the executive
producer of ballerina and i cannot
believe that
since we launched
to highlight one of the most vital
pieces of our own you know
honestly in the first place
together we ran a fan vote to name the
best emerging streamer from our global
community list
we'll announce the winner before the end
of the show and then we'll all go raid
their stream together
again i want to thank you all for
playing and i'll leave you with just a
taste of what we've all done together
this year
a lot of cool premiere the potential i
love it
i feel like a lot of the premieres are
going to be here
four hours
[Music]
oh this music do music's the best music
yeah get your message
a lot
[Music]
we've partnered with our friends at
pokemon go on the water fish pokemon and
throughout the night
we'll let you know when large numbers of
whooper will appear in the wild
we've also been told you could encounter
a shiny whooper if you're lucky so
open up pokemon go and catch some
whooper while you watch
this evening
chat ganda asked do we think the big
bombshell has already dropped
[Music]
oh
because i was like oh wait a minute
we've played that here before
award-winning
welcome to reality baby sure thing champ
lead the way if you could only find your
gun
[Music]
with full voice acting for every single
one of the city's
um yes i'm going to unplug the
microphone okay
[Music]
yeah please
i hope this comes to console forever
did you just give props to stadium what
other games do they have now
[Laughter]
we got this [ __ ] at it
ain't nobody on that side paying 60
dollars
we already know right here so excited
because xbox looked at it and said we're
not paying that premium let them have it
well now we're going to talk about
bioware
a little sneak preview of what to expect
in the next game
we got that same thing right here god
bless but that is not the same as
discord
oh i've been waiting for this one
because they said they're announcing
this someone
bent on breaking the world
oh dragon age oh yeah oh i didn't expect
that that's good they did say the rumors
were like it was going to show
let's see i love you
the kind of person
[Music]
[Applause]
next we'll have a look at an exciting
new tactical squad based
roguelite game set in the endless
universe
for someone that didn't care about that
oh sega oh this looks kind of cool
[Music]
[Music]
this song is chill oh this is like back
of the
bar this dude
he's the last dude that whiskey night
yeah yeah that's last call but they try
to kick you
he listening to the dude and the drummer
man in the back
yeah that's what definitely the spot in
the pumpkin
yeah i mean i'll take all the hate by
like the same track
that's cool where you going in though
you going there for
oh this is kind of cool look up this is
like almost like a smash tv box game
yeah i like that look at the four player
little diablo
series x okay yeah that's why they said
keep that other stuff that's all game
that's a game pass day one
you're acting like it's what uh endless
dungeons very cool
the new open world action adventure so
how is that saying it's why can you say
everything is getting better
everything should be being said oh my
god
actual gameplay footage this is the
beautiful
and merciless dungeon of crimson for pc
for a while
no crimson desert
is like you know black desert black
desert online
it's super grindy so it's really
interesting to see that they're making
another
franchise but is it going to be an mmo
though
but the thing that's like darker
missiles all they do is just go around
just
hold on now oh no this is in game
if there's a single player they might be
onto a winner
are they actually moving like when i
look out the window to go to work
wait a second cause black desert
is that rdna too
machine learning oh my god i'm gonna
have some ai coming in here soon
how are the clouds there's the power to
the cloud oh [ __ ]
3d audio sound acoustic ear drums
can i use the adaptive triggers
how about my numbing rumble
this looks like game of thrones yeah
though yeah i see that that's true yeah
but the hate blowing the cape with the
the lotus blocks okay this this this
looks like a single plane yeah
it looks very ambitious
i don't know about you yeah i see what
you're talking about i do see very stoic
oh oh i thought he's gonna punch him in
his face
yeah this looks very single player oh
old execution
oh look at that it might be oh
the chicken said send the lannisters to
your regards
gameplay
they got the loading screen i like this
gameplay though oh look at that look at
that he jumped over
[Music]
oh
yeah they got a little bit of that loads
of technical issues but the
the scope a lot of blood crazy yeah
this is this is that's rude
that's one that's one thing that black
desert does not i mean uh
yes
they got everybody's feature in their
game yeah they like everybody everything
that's hot
they got it you got dragons
no no i'll still be doing that
oh they got pitfall harry style
oh the bear the beer oh the lightning
man just had to sort of almost in his
hand under thunder
this is so legit there's so much going
on in this game
i want to know who is photos this is
very ambitious
i feel like these guys have totally
completely kept this thing under
the key so nobody really knows about it
they may ever play shadows
yes they
what is the game not doing i want this
game what is the game not doing at this
point
that's no count oh you can you can ride
beast yes
this this game is the dude kingdom said
this is mr me too the game
[Laughter]
so whatever you doing we got that
ghost from my call of duty he's just
gonna pop out of like the snow at some
point
[Music]
oh is it one of those uh korean games
i don't
he joined me in fortnight earlier this
year the star of tenet
john david washington hey just got 324
in the chat
into the game as you know when
christopher nolan's the latest film
tenant i played a character called the
protagonist
very literally named narrative and i
thought that was cool enough for the
character it reminded me a little bit of
playing video ideas where
where were all the protagonists coming
out
of choices you know i mean that was
supposed to be his big moment
that feeling of being in control but
also being kind in the situation
storytellers
could be false so these are the nominees
best narrative
[Music]
and the game award goes too oh man the
last of us
last of us i didn't care what it was
yeah
all right first oh wait acceptance for
each other
no offense but i don't know how they can
put a remake
in a game to win again i just
don't understand this even though it is
a great challenge
you shouldn't be able to
james and of course the entire nazis
you know what happened to red dead
that's what's gonna happen to the last
of us
i want
[Laughter]
some people just want the world to burn
i do and i'm definitely one of those
people right now
[Music]
[Laughter]
my swedish it's a little rusty but i
think there's been um
[Music]
[Music]
he has real human
[Music]
[Music]
are you a flag he's pulling something
for the whole team
that's amazing all right well
congratulations sweetest chef
uh this time it's real swedish chef is
playable
and overcooked all you can eat on ps5
and xbox
and he's available
gillette to introduce the game awards
future class
a group of thinkers dreamers and
pioneers who represent the bright
exclusive future
really changed my life to be honest with
you my name is royce payne i'm a senior
computer science major at morales
college and i'm currently playing on the
morehouse maroon tiger gaming team
we see other big colleges able to have
these gaming teams
and they're winning scholarships for us
not to have it we're like
this is a lack we need to get rid of
this lack
we're just a collection of
different passionate gamers who want to
compete against one another
we've played against some good
competition so far just being able to
really break into that space and open
the door for others to come behind me
that's
huge for me
this
[Music]
oh hi everyone i hope you're enjoying
the game awards i'm alana pierce coming
at you live from
my mansion as someone with a chronic
respiratory illness i've had to find
some unique ways to deal with
20 20 situations like maybe i go for a
swim in my
olympic sized but that's not a lot the
olympic one
but i know that there are some people
out there watching this that are
depending on things
however the high levels of nicotine that
you can be enhancing you can actually
worsen your anxiety and just kind of
fight against the mental health battle
that is
this year not that i would know because
you'll move
relax yourself chad see what y'all doing
but that doesn't mean i'm not trying to
look out for you
for those of you who are looking to quit
vaping you are
this is quitting is a free textbook
[Laughter]
the message
you got 367 in the chat let's hit that
like subscribe and [ __ ]
[Music]
oh yo yo i'm gonna tell you right now
a little by little nintendo has been
working it out
i ain't seen nothing from sony did you
see the sephiroth reveal
for spanish oh he didn't say oh my god
attic you missed it it was about that
mario music it was fun all right back to
him
we've got two game developers coming
together to make a real franchise
tonight
they're teaming up again for this epic
game store world reveal
which you can play come on right now
come on sony now let's go
wow
you know what i really need to make
quick five
yes any casualties are ignored
no progress
[Music]
[Applause]
middle of it welcome back to the game
awards earlier i asked you
for free right now in the epic story
let's check out a couple you want to be
on steam you got to pay them
prices looking great keep posting on
instagram
thank you very much sid last month
there's so many things
to unravel a conspiracy theory with the
release of black ops cold war
on december 16th season one kicks off
free multiplayer maps more weapons and
more operators and for war zone players
a massive update of content including a
new close quarters map
rebirth island here's your first look at
the gameplay of season
season one warzone
[Music]
premiere
that wears chasing ghosts he has some
pieces of the puzzle but doesn't know
he's a piece himself
he won't live long enough to work that
out
[Music]
because the figures are separated
i am going to enjoy this
[Music]
a bad time out though
[Music]
mercy hell yeah he showed me
this
took them like a year to come up with
another map yeah they think they're very
good
yeah he's rolled out like four maps this
year yeah
in defensive card they're engine though
it's
totally different all flashing
this is an anniversary year yeah
super mario brothers originally released
in 1985
here to perform a medley of mario songs
the legendary
abbey road studios in london what are
you talking about 35th anniversary
philharmonic orchestra
they've been around the same amount of
time super mario brothers
and that's it for me get you out this is
the moment where i check out
when they when they got the whole
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
your eggs are tuned just as he goes down
one of the tubes yo separate is killing
everybody
he's watching some other damn net i'm
i'm done with it
see you guys later
[Music]
killed everybody
so
[Music]
that kind of makes everything better
doesn't it wow
harmonic they'll be back again later in
the show and eddie vetter's coming up
too so
lots of shows still to come lots of us
are in lockdown right now i know it
might feel normal tonight to see all
these games but
we're all on lockdown and i know we all
can't wait to go back
outside to travel the world meet new
people well until then
here is a game where you can do all of
that as you explore and record
disappearing cultures
in a strange beautiful world this game
is just stunning and it's coming to
playstation 5.
check it out ps5 microsoft flight sim
rival
oh no
[Music]
our grandparents said they saw that king
left when they started playing certain
places
they knew it was okay to themselves uh
to be honest king which is up slander
for them
to be honest it's not for me it's for me
so far i like the art style i always
love ourselves like this
but us but i got to see gabe play like
what is it what you do
we have one season photos
[Music]
yeah the visuals were nice seasons all
right well now it's time to present
another
game award she's the star of the
upcoming film wonder woman in 1984
here's the power of the ssd guys oh my
god y'all
take it up for king i see to be here
political or deeply the games for
impact award honors socially progressive
projects
that have the potential
in the world here are the nominees that
will relax yourself gaming
[Music]
nothing good comes from stirring up old
memories we don't really have a choice
about that
[Music]
yo she said the ssd could make that bike
go faster
[Applause]
me why and on behalf of the entire team
from both dotnote entertainment and
xbox publishing thank you so much for
this award and thank you so much for all
the love that you've shown tyler and
allison
and their journey i'd like to express
our team's deep admiration for all of
tonight's
nominees especially those that have used
their problems
to tell stories about trans and queer
people
with sincerity and heart here's to a
future where even more marginalized
people can see themselves and their
experiences
truly reflected in the games they play
thank you so so much
salute yeah definitely congratulations
everyone's joining us the tech is
working this is amazing and it's so cool
to see everyone
um all right well right now we've got
another brand new game announcement for
you
check this out unexpected world for me
let's
get it let's get it
i love when this man says unexpected let
me look at this
uh okay oh that looked like full motion
video at first
that's how i look good that look wait
what's this
video what's
up
you know the budget is big they got
vacations this better be faster than
furious
they got no budget is big the check has
been cut
they got vin out here vin diesel but
don't you know how they're all just
letting these people gang up on them i
know
right like surround them the others are
gonna do nothing
oh man my guy is going chronicles ridic
on him
kind of crazy
oh
that can't go straight at you
what is this they're putting up yeah
they're spending a lot of time on this
dude
is crazy they could afford an engine
and vision dude
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is this come on dietrich
he said the cgi trailer does that
remember is this a new arc
i don't know it's like crazy oh arc they
need to borrow a whole bunch if they did
this
i'll be in if this you can get dizzy it
looked like that thing on her arm was
from art
yeah the arctic oh yeah
diesel this is a departure from the old
graphics yeah
that means they got a budget if
[Music]
but why are you hating on his gains why
are you hating on his games daniel he
could have been working out
connected i think this is art because
that looks like the
that thing that you have in our hands
right yeah it does very feel arcish
ain't gonna lie horizon zero vin diesel
i already told you
primal rage i am i said that oh no
octave and diesel edition oh okay
oh dizzy popsicle crazy dizzy
that's right arc 2 starring vin diesel
and the team at studio wild card
has one more announcement
everyone now everybody as soon as they
find out or start a game
yo y'all found that you foul for that
as soon as you find out that does not
what if they really did that if they
really did they're
well played but i mean maybe they
rebuilt it off in the engine
previously leonardo says for this says
hold up
when did they finish the first one so
they can make the second
that's true savage
because you never escaped the outside i
said them servers got to be 56k if they
spend
half that money
yo kai stupid he said the off dams has
eaten ramen for five years
this is still ark that they got
got a bag they got a game they got an
animators
your arm is the who cash infused uh
i bet i bet you i bet you they're about
to announce that microsoft
jerry look at this jeffy jeffrey
come on now come on how do they get this
money off oh what's going on man i gotta
we gotta look into y'all records we
gotta
phenomenon and we all had fun with it uh
this summer especially when we were off
to knock down this holiday season fall
guys is back with a win we had to do a
federal investigation
[Music]
what just happened wonderful time
it's fall guys
it's the most
[Music]
gotta i gotta snitch something
something's up
there's no way they made that much money
off josiah
steve said it's the game pass buddy
[Music]
they took the xbox's money and made an
anatomy
that game barely ran at 10 frames per
second
and now they got enough did you see that
lineup they got
christmassy russell crowe
big diesel jeffrey wright
[Applause]
i'm sorry i hate the i hate to hate i'm
gonna have to six
nine i'm at the six though
i need people to call cognito out on
being the six
nine i'm six dollars at the iop do not
do not agree i gotta i gotta look into
that money of
all we gotta investigate uh you own with
geforce now you can check that out uh
the game festival lots
of televisions and games you can play
all weekend long
tom holland nolan north and the award
for best multiplayer more awards and
announcements and later
we've got racism
here is the gameplay reveal of odyssey
which lets you explore on foot
for the first time this set arc has the
only fan's page
i'm done with y'all i'm done with you
[Music]
guys
oh pearl jam boys disco's coming out
xbox few months later
ground control to major tongues
ground control to major tongue
bars
take your protein pills and put
[Music]
it's your people
who is
i'm about to go play cyberpunk
i think we all need a way of coping
shout out new zealand with what's going
on in the world
games is an incredible way of doing that
i'm
jennifer hayes and they say that game
pass is not profitable
in mental health we launched that
federal investigation something
clicked you gotta check all of it i
realized that
all my life i've been using video games
as a way of nurturing my own well-being
and i wondered if other people could do
that too
hi this is and so i established
checkpoint to bring mental health
resources
to the gaming community what is mental
health we use
games as a medium to raise awareness
and to reduce stigma always down to
provide real
tangible resources to people who are
struggling that they can
use in their everyday life oh they're
there
life is strange it's okay
at the moment i hope they can but i
don't see them ever making a game as
good as that game yeah that gate was
for there for you welcome to enoch a
hell hole of madness and misery
if you don't want to end up as worm food
what works for you in the old world
of survival
yeah that's right you can use cover
nobody's stopping what's this game
you're a biological sledgehammer
you've got a kill
is like right here you
have to
[Music]
video games
is
[Music]
[Music]
i know you
so just out of curiosity the chat do you
guys like the
the uh videos being down there at the
bottom
i'm just curious uh yeah let us know
we're messing around man
we need feedback for me well
yes but you're the home team yeah yeah i
can't i can't i can't tell you you're
gonna say
we gotta tell people like nah man it's
trash y'all go back to the old drinks
all right all right it's fine looks good
thank you all right thank you
okay i appreciate it we're gonna be
doing more
more stuff with us
[Music]
look you guys you guys have uh uh you
guys are the real people
this is on dna yeah kybasa agrees with
you
kaibatsu's ocd is just like he said yes
center middle center
oh man they even at the xbox partnership
with it oh
man okay
danielson makes it good when you do see
clips with y'all hey what's up guys
it's uh tom holland here i am in atlanta
on the set of the next spider-man film
but i am honored to be a part of the
game awards tonight
you know that for the past few years
i've been working on the uncharted movie
which did involve some extensive
research playing the games
i'm honored to be playing nathan drake
what i can assure you
is that we really want to honor naughty
dogs amazing games
so this film tells you how nathan drake
because
you call me when it's over oh it's now
my honor all right
here you guys go man nathan drake please
welcome
mr nolan north
[Music]
you know someday when someone searches
for nathan drake on imdb
and you are the first result i will only
be remarkably bitter
you know video games allow us to connect
with friends
family and complete strangers shout out
to donald trump share memorable
experiences beyond the comments
i don't know i don't believe those
financial side of years i've been
grateful for multiplayer gamepl
[Music]
it's a big one and the game award goes
too
oh oh we got it we got it
oh you got this is the one with you like
addict on your own on this one right
no we both say among us i i convinced
you at the last minute
okay good good good thing i listen to
this thank you game awards and everyone
who voted for they deserve this
um imagine their thought
process when they won best multiplayer
when they made a game in 2018
and the rest is history now more than
ever finding ways to connect with
friends is increasingly significant
and we're so happy many of you turn to
among us to play
with friends of the team that he's got
on the phone
robot teddy duel studio and our other
partners
for helping us navigate all the
excitement
thank you so much thank you kind of
defeating
[Applause]
supernatural horror franchises and it
looks like a
bloody i'm going to say the ones i want
and i'm going to highlight thank you so
much
tony said yes video at the bottom allows
us watches to take a look at whoever at
any time
i like it quite a bit thank you brother
that was my idea oh my god i had a real
life
once i had a wonderful girlfriend
okay and wants to disturb the other we
drove to a small cat oh
oh
he wasn't
i really like that that humongous thing
it just showed how much passions in this
industry and people
get really excited to get recognized you
know what i'm saying
in the woods yeah wow even dead the game
classic stick is all over this
no no no no you should date no one
should have left evil dead
as a cult classic movie they shouldn't
do this
really there you go eagle game a classic
game franchise
is being remade i know so many people
are gonna play people so much of this
game thank you
yo people gonna spread bread for that
bro yeah that's amazing
all right i'll play the game if i'm not
here
[Music]
let's
this was dark souls before dark souls
this is this game was so damn hard
oh my god y'all know what time it is
tell them young boys what dark souls was
before
it was this this does not look hard this
is shut up
dark souls before dark souls this is
dark souls
before when you beat one dark souls when
you beat one gold
kills
then talk to me
we love ourselves some capcom arcade
classics we're now going to recognize
some more
winners in the category of best
independent games
the nominees are carrion fall guys
ultimate knockout
haiti hades winners
half-life alex resident evil three and
the last of us part two
and our winner is yeah the last of us
is the last game role player
this year our final fantasy come on we
need this
we need this video and yakuza like
address
and the game award goes to this girl we
did it
the the best of best
simulation or strategy game those
nominees are crusader kings
desperado's three gears tactics
microsoft flight simulator
chimera squad and the winner is wow okay
oh i did that too i think i think i'm
going to win crown of the lord this year
i think i'm winning this year you voted
tournament style to pick your favorite
games the final five nominees were
willingness
like you're two ahead right now now
we've got i've never won crown
what's up hey ralph you know who wins
this no how would i
i mean we haven't even read the nominees
yet not you which one is this because
i'm not fighting games
karate kid for nintendo 1987
yo karate was weak all right eugene
listen
whatever okay why don't we just read off
the list of nominees
fighting games grand blue fantasy versus
mortal kombat 11 that's ultimate
and the winner is look how easy he did
that
one of the things i have really i've
been missing this year is flying around
the world but luckily you know it's
crazy the most beautiful games
different game of the year
xbox airborne view of our wonderful
world you've ruined the vice versa this
is a big deal it's a big deal
what is flight similarity of world
premiere for xbox for series x this is a
big deal
oh eventually i'm behind you on 4k
satellite
[Music]
[Music]
this game
what a wonderful world
that look nice
[Music]
bust your data cap though if you ain't
got it oh yeah there's a bunch of data
capture that's serious
guys make sure you got a limited data
with your network if you're buying this
all right uh microsoft simulator looks
amazing coming
next summer to xbox and now it's time to
take a look
at another game coming to playstation 5.
playstation
world premiere playstation studios
oh
like the music already
the music is five i think i remembered
it for me
it's it's they've announced this not
familiar
oh yes we've seen this before
it reminds me of los angeles yes little
lost well i feel good
oh yeah we've seen the dash the dash
mechanic
return looks cool marched us soon
another
end another beginning
close things up all right
we will be back in just a moment with a
ma'am i mean a man a meme a legend
reggie he's going to
join us a new look at a game from a guy
you might remember from one of the
craziest most unscripted abilities
in game awards history
will play his song from the last of us
part two and later jacksepticeye
joins us from europe to present content
creator of the year
fantastic
my answer to this question used to be
did you see the obi-wan kenobi series
has been announced as well
you and mcgregor mcgregor
lose again
what's up
okay okay you know epic really
backed a good corner with that game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes it's actually fun i mean
i enjoyed it
it's even took some of the destiny
stream oh yeah
like when you get some of the characters
and you start getting all their power
moves and stuff
[Music]
i want to have any type of like raid
activity
mechanic
[Music]
hn impact is not available on xbox
but i got a pc fan
[Music]
ultra japanese animator
another example of microsoft not getting
certain these games
over here man yeah but i think this is
more of an exclusive hi i am mary mouser
along with from netflix's cobra kai
we're here to settle one of the great
rides yeah but i feel like they're
relating to
those from the last week
it's a hard
you gotta expand your horizons yeah oh
it's expensive
[Music]
like there's limits this little let's
look that's right
next time you go to the street with your
camera because i got to see your face
you're in rare form right now
[Music]
how are you from the border
[Music]
early beta this is like one of my first
taxes i covered this game
is usually good
i might have to stream this for the iop
yo addict we covered this game
the dev had the game on a laptop
it was so early alpha this looks like
like a telltale like
yeah a lot of choice driven procedural i
remember this whole thing
yeah wow this had to be 2017. yeah we'll
hit them up
i think this has to be 2017 just like
what our first taxes
[Music]
hp oh shout out to hp omen in the
building
debuting
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a look at a new road coming to rogue
company um so make sure to check that
out uh this holiday season all right
well you probably remember this next
developer from a few years back he is
not a fan of the oscars but he is a fan
of colorful language and art oh you
already know who it is
you know who it is to give us a new look
no way out there next game
here is my body he really is my friend
joseph faraz
he didn't look like your friend when he
was yeah like you were scared to death
but he was loose back at the game awards
as you can see i'm surprised he's
letting him do that again
they love him it takes two trust me when
i say this
hazel is next co-op only experience it
takes two
it's gonna blend narrative and a huge
variety of gameplay reviews because of
how
well i know
anyway we're also going to have
something that we had in a way out we
call a friend's pass which means
you buy one copy and you got your man
corrupt that's a great concept
if you play with your friend you can
play with free time
with me anyway it's coming out march
26th enjoy the trailer
goodbye it takes two to make a thing
[Music]
that's the name of the cave this is the
story of the love
one of wizards and worries
kids and a big dame sent upon the high
seas
look at these dolls almost forgot they
used to be humans
do you want to know what this story is
really about
perhaps it's the story
of cody oh
and man oh they
you got transformed a blob of play wanna
change back then you need to fix
your relationship
supported by ea
this is a story of passion
[Music]
[Laughter]
but probably not at launch not not um
okay i got this give me some space i
need to think
wow
i mean yo i am mike's a kicking ass
playing
cody
[Music]
you yeah philly eagle somebody gotta
like this game not me
living flame i'm copping this okay look
look look
i'm gonna buy it just because i like the
dude who made it well i said
you kid got a new players to fix your
relationship that's the game is about
fixing relationships
[Music]
[Applause]
what an absolutely crazy game joseph
shows like he is on sunday
we have to show this out there
all right now i'd like to welcome a long
time friend and supporter of the game
awards he was there
in vegas for our very first show back in
hebrews 14 and he's been back
every year since we weren't going to let
the streak stop this year the retired
president and co from nintendo of
america reggie but
still a boss regifizame reggie
jeff jeff how you doing i'm doing good
reggie take it away
absolutely you know i'm proud to present
the very first award for innovation
in accessibility during my time at
nintendo
we had a mantra gaming for the masses
and we pushed that agenda with we
nintendo ds
and now i
[Music]
that makes gaming challenging for them
this award was created
to highlight the efforts throughout the
gaming industry
to make software and hardware that
enables games to be played and enjoyed
by the widest and most inclusive
audience possible
because gaming is for everyone
here are the nominees nominee for what
innovation in excess of innovation
except accessibility
i think we all said last of us too
because they really went hard
[Music]
what size you shouldn't be getting a
reward for this this [ __ ] you should
be part of gaming yeah the last of us
partners
master bus clean sleep that's like
four awards i'm telling you what
happened to red dead redemption is going
to happen to the last of us
and from everyone thank
as developers we know how one small
design
it
decisions
but they had an argument and he locked
his wife
studios our senior producer sam thompson
the user experience research team and
our dedicated accessibility qa testers
and we'd also like to thank everybody at
naughty dog
this was truly a team effort and every
department had a perfect place
to thank you the players nothing makes
us prouder
than hearing stories from players who
are able to experience the last of us
part two
without assistance using our
accessibility features to remove
barriers that would have otherwise
excluded them
from both of us thank you so much thank
you
congratulations to naughty dog such an
important category and i'm proud that
we're able to recognize innovation and
accessibility here at the game awards
we're gonna do that every year moving
forward
this next world premiere gives us our
first glimpse at next year's
adventures just for the elder scrolls
online casually waiting to
pick up the game of the year award at
the end will will elder scrolls
bring me back premiere oh oh oh this is
time
no it's out the scrolls online oh a lot
this is my game this is
where they going next please tell me
they're going to the argonia
come on this is swan it's it looks like
the black mash
but
because they did skyrim they did so
that's got to be the plug
that's probably just an oblivion oh
well yeah if they've got they did skyrim
last year as their big expansion
so i'm assuming feeling very obliviony
well yeah this isn't good
oblivion is really without being held i
believe it was an early
360 title i would have said oh okay
so we're doing all the outer scrolls
from imposters
and among us to the visual beauty of gen
impact
mobile gaming has had an incredible year
coming up i'll be revealing the winner
of best mobile game presented by lg wing
the world's first
5g swivel smartphone powered by qualcomm
snapdragon
and later the first look at a brand new
map
from among us the game awards we'll be
right back
we got what we got commercial between
london
they know who the gold is you know what
it is
part of that 167 million that's right
baby so that's
all dusty
and that 60 frames per second patch
could load
good lowest 120 frames crucible
oh no but you can keep that stacey said
crucible
just fine
it's time for the warlocks tony yo tony
bryant that's 60 frames a bit different
right
bro back prophecy let's go look at the
ring the old vector of the building
y'all know what it is
the raid bro this is the perfect time
perfect time 3.99 for game pass
new night for new players slid out here
oh god show the vaulter glass right at
the end do it do it
do it i need that vaulted glass reveal
oh yes that looked like a yes
i just want atheon to appear in the
they've already confirmed it's
definitely covered
i know i want a destiny
no there's no atm reveal
you know what's something i noticed
there what's up
that was an anthem with the vision
yo you messi
[Music]
where are they at in the video game
awards savage
that's huge with that budget they got
shout out to the quest tool oculus in
the building dude
i wouldn't be surprised in the next like
couple months they say they bought it
because that's a really good game for
gamepad
[Music]
easy watch your mouth
[Music]
internal ssds on the market the sn 850
nvme
ssd with heatsink what
what
so why are you advertising an ssd
ssd up get it up
ssd show yeah but i mean
i mean the wt black is a good brand
oh yeah how did i beat it different ssd
we've just heard from our friends at
pokemon go that there is
another surge of looper appearing so
we're implementing
which introduces quarterly seasons
raises the level cap to 50.
and makes earning
like chess pin fennekin and froakie
are also making their pages go debut
there's also a lot of bonuses happening
now and it's never been a better time
to play pokemon go
[Music]
they've always known you would come okay
okay
do you know why you have
secrets see i i love the old
oh wow
if you are to face what's coming
you must find oh boy
let me not play this show
[Laughter]
our next award she's a host and producer
from ign and your host for the game
awards pre-show
this is sydney goodman
[Applause]
mobile games were once defined by their
limitations
in a way we celebrated the games that
excelled despite their platform
as technology has closed the gap
releasing on phones is no longer
a limitation it's an asset it's never
been
more apparent than tonight where the
nominees for best mobile game have found
massive audiences because of their
platform
impact will probably win this game
presented by lg wing and qualcomm
snapdragon oh
we all picked it
i need a big league just in case you get
game of the year right and the game
award
goes too i don't think hades is getting
it oh
my gosh oh all of us wrong
among us is out here and you you
remember me wanting to vote for him i
remember you wanted to do it too
oh my gosh thank you again game awards i
blame slow-mo for that loss
you got me thinking that in my life all
the other games
it's fine though man since all of us got
wrong
it's okay so if you found yourself with
a group of friends
um you could easily set up a game we
wanted our game to be accessible at any
level of gamer and wanted to create a
mobile behavior
to be shared amongst friends and family
and whoever
uh we want to thank our players
um whether you played among us when it
was mobile local only
or played for the first time just
yesterday thank you from the four of us
um
for the past two years and a big thank
you again to our friends and family
we love you and miss you and thank you
for being so supportive
thank you thank you thank you oh man
congratulations to among us second win
of the night
next up the monster hunter franchise is
coming to the nintendo switch in 2021
this is a new look at monster hunter
i'll probably never play
so far so good
a huge pack of monsters in a giant
stampede
they attacked the village
nobody knows why this happens we gotta
make sure it's not copyrighted
yo capcom fam my identifier they said
the lawyers at you
say let's get some warriors to send it
out
get on it
[Music]
[Music]
and how are you going to time the video
game
bush is in time wow
savage interest oh what's up lord gene
36 trailers not gonna happen lord jean
if you want in holla
holla at me
all right over on twitch the next poll
is for content creator of the year
voting for you i think is going to win
and we'll find out a little bit who wins
that category
but next up he's one of our industry's
great performers and he plays joel in
the last of us
here he's troy baker troy baker
he's a really good voice actor one day
on the set of the last of us part one
neil our writer and director asked me
and ashley
what we would have been if we weren't
actors i thought about it for a second
and replied that
i always imagined i would have been a
singer ashley just shrugged and
in her charming and off-handed way said
it would have been an astronaut
neil incorporated parts of us into ellie
and joel
space and music became major elements of
their stories creating
touching moments between them one of
those moments
now indelible in our memories
incorporated neil's story as well
not as a writer but as a father last of
us
every night that song was pearl jam's
one day neil asked if i was comfortable
playing it in a scene he was writing for
the last of his party
now i don't generally get nervous but oh
yeah i understood what that song meant
to neil and to the game
dude i'm surprised a lot of appearances
are not even close to winning
but nobody can play it better than the
christian huge following
from seattle performing future days
here's
cute as well but
[Music]
she's not just
[Music]
if i take the game away from it and just
view it as a song
i'll give it
give us the rating what's the rating so
far what attempt
you don't know the song so far would you
like
to know him and i know they're uh it is
from the last of us
give me the rain what's your what's your
vibe rating right now everything he
writes
is legitimate like you're like
you feel sad yeah
[Music]
[Music]
i'll give it like i'll give it like a
solid seven just on the fact that
okay dutch where are we at
maybe like that's me yeah
[Music]
music
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're excited to be working with studio
wild card team in brini
art two starring vanities exclusively to
the xbox whoa
they gave arc a budget one if phil
dropped a bet
dude i i i willing to bet you that
they're they're buying that studio
sooner or later they're going to buy
this i will say this
if if microsoft got something to do with
the bag then i'll cut out my
investigation
shout out to flint for uh uh tweeting me
thank you
if you're in the chat man shout out to
that one you're the real vip
i'll stop you you're more of a vip than
this dude on this guitar could ever be
i'll stop by federal level and
um i really appreciate the way that was
you already said the emails man it
doesn't work like this it's not actually
brilliant yeah
joel and ellie speak to the lawyers
together phil
phil got that that okay but that that's
a legitimate source of income
not arc by itself perhaps pick up
something a little bit more upbeat on
though wake everybody up with this
pick everybody loved one um
but it is nice to be part of this
uh
he won't do the behind the music with
him he doesn't understand he doesn't
even
know where he's talking doesn't get
better than that thank you so much
eddie better for being here on the game
awards all right now here's another
brand new game to show you
for the first time people had time
[Music]
maybe refresh this
looking like on my man from mortal
kombat
looking like errol black i feel like
this is too white for you to comment on
this this look like how red they're
supposed to be so i could like it
i'd be action are they futuristic
it's just not just
that's cognito sunday trying to get this
bend the knees
but this is the cg trailer so we need to
see gameplay yes esperado's isn't it
daniel said koala juarez the medic said
call of durez
everyone's saying the chat listen i want
you to put it
into the bushes if it looks trash or or
put it
put up across their horns if this game
was lit
seriously
okay chat like they put the horns up
there is there any games the winners in
content creator of the year
and the twitch audience uh
with uh 44 of the is going to win so the
award for
content creator of the year is coming up
next presented by adobe and artist boss
logic
you know how loki knew that she was
great
and fortnite but right now this is an
upcoming action jrpg
from bandai namco here's a look at the
brand new trick you told jeff anywhere
that uh white sneaks with a black suit
was
like it was a good idea virtual
brainling cable
um much more than i did in training
because this this is uh just going obs
to mute this like
cat palm is crazy with the coffee right
structure
oh
and after a certain amount of time i
just i deleted it
yeah this is angel nexus yeah
it actually looks cool it's called
scarlet next yeah
either way either way you mispronounced
the name
it's an anime game and i'm into anime
games
yeah they were five i like uh all right
philly maybe those five games you like
because you will put bush in the whole
show
don't underestimate me oh this is day
one okay finally something's illegal
like
don't bother tell me he don't look like
something he'll obtain this
so from sort out the line god let that
happen
nah he
[Music]
music
[Music]
xbox oh xbox through the back behind
that one
for me i am often depressed when i look
i bet you that zelda game is going to be
out of
where we are in terms of depression and
anxiety
and inattention we owe it to all the
people that are suffering to be really
creative and to try things that when you
first hear it
sound crazy like a video game is
medicine my name is adam gazali
i am a neuroscientist and mental health
show it started for me 12 years ago i
became really interested in the world
like
seriously experiences as a way of
improving brain function
and this relies on a principle called
neuroplasticity the fact that our brain
shapes itself and modifies to make sure
it was response to the challenge
all right so so that's how this is going
to create a video game
that was carefully designed to challenge
and reward the brain in a very specific
way
and so it just happened a couple of
months ago the fda cleared endeavor rx
as a medical device to treat inattention
to children
that have adhd this is the first time
ever i i think i might have missed some
video games
talk me into going with hate is a
dangerous place
only the best can keep it safe the best
art direction
that one was tier 1
wasn't that best art director position
unfortunately
you are just generally better humans and
the world needs you
here at the peak humanity procreation
facility gamers from around the globe
are donating their superior dna
i'm donating i'm donating i have
powerful swim swims and it can be yours
transcend humanity through gaming that's
audio design that was live stores
[Music]
best performance i don't think i was
there for
ea that it's in the game
hey chad who won best performance
should it be on the website yeah
maybe they're doing it live
i think king might be right there with
you man yeah it can't get on
he's been on fire with a couple of games
too
it's really gonna like we're we're all
winning them it's just like some of them
it's really gonna come down to
that's what's gonna
yes you just tuned into the initiative
show yes is a perfect dark
they showed welcome back and as you just
saw ea play is available now on new
consoles steam and origin it includes
star wars jedi fallen order
one of our nominees all right now on to
one of the biggest games this year was
created by three developers in seattle
now four you spot them they've won two
awards tonight
they absolutely took over the internet
they sent us something special this is
the reveal of the brand new
map for among us check it out crewmates
we gotta all play this one time i agree
black running dress we like dragon ages
day and date free i don't know if it's
day and date
dragon j uh it'll probably be the 10
hour trial
for ea game class gameplay in this
welcome recruit get yourself acquainted
with the layout of the that airship
enough slacking go to your tasks
[Music]
oh man there's so many places
quit grouping up choose a room to start
oh wait you could choose a room
someone keeps trying to sabotage us stop
their plan
keep your eyes peeled we definitely have
an impostor here
oh new finishers
that's nice i like that
[Music]
day one dutch
they came to me and said all right we
can do this what's my request anyways
uh jeff keeley match now available
all right he's a hilarious content
creator with over 25 million subs and
over 13 billion views he's joining us
now
live from the uk jacksepticeye hello
jack
what's up hello jeff how's it going
hello everyone at the game awards
in a year when so many of us were
separated from our family and friends
one thing remained the same our favorite
content creators were still there for us
their streaming gaming and sharing
helped us fill the hours
and feel connected unifying us all with
our shared
passion for play here are the nominees
for content creators
are you proud of me who is this
wait hold on wait hold up hold up wow
wow wow wow it's between him and
valkyrie
yeah i'm going valkyrie yes
between that dude and valkyrie
and the game award goes to yep
valkyray congratulations thank god i
wasn't
going to make this category to the game
my awards and family and
fans and my loving community
for being so supportive i want to sing
something but i don't want to
seven or so years of streaming and now
she got in with
thank you so much for the support i am
very flattered and honored
to accept this award um and yeah
you could totally even know what to say
and all gaming creators around the world
tonight celebrate your creativity by
downloading a free trial of
the 11th place that she looks sucks
adobe.com
she does play a lot of among us man
joining me right now is the chief
creative officer of epic games
donald mustard uh donald it is great to
have you on the show it's a yearly
tradition
new fortnight season
it's the best i'm the only one
you know what killed but got me yeah i
got microsoft simulator uh
looking for
youtube some of the best destiny
concentration some of the best
i want to be i want to be politically
correct with what you do
well you got to start singing the real
song man you gotta start singing
[Music]
chief is here for a day there i mean we
already pretty much knew that
let's get it thanks for having me guys
ice cream everybody have a great night
you're getting them all donald isn't
that crazy like
master chief is just one of my most
favorite characters ever
in anything and i'm just we're so
thrilled that he can
join the ever-growing cast of characters
and and we'll already put creators into
this book he's going to be available
in fortnite you can go and and get
master chief
and i know there's some more halo coming
as well i heard
oh yeah so i think uh you know we didn't
want to
stop right there and so there's
something else i think we should uh
oh no hello battle royale it's an honor
red versus blue
what's going on are you here huh i guess
you already got the news
what news master chief is coming to
fortnite
what now it's all the breakfast popular
video games
in the world but more obviously been a
long time since then
right now yeah wait a minute if you had
no idea
battle royale box you have a cardboard
cut out of master chief
perfectly regular reasons whoa
you guys new around here ninja no the
chief got eliminated by a sneaky blue
that's no blue that's that's ninja
it's such an honor i'm a huge fan of
yours on twitch twitch
is he twitching cause he's blue stop
making us look bad in front of ninja
we're sergeant griff from the popular
web series red versus blue
you probably watched it about 10 years
ago what are you doing here
well it's more than just the chief
coming to fortnite this map is too
it'll be in creative mode starting at 10
a.m eastern time tomorrow
oh so that's what we're doing in
ragnarok you mean
basin yeah i'm pretty sure it was called
something else
either way you can start reliving your
favorite halo memories here in fortnite
and maybe add your own personal style
everybody said crazy
come on ninja what do you say uh
save it for nears now they setting up
the uh the halo infinite battle royale
now
red versus blue donald
[Applause]
yeah isn't that so awesome and so funny
um so what's awesome about that is
that uh blood gulch was recreated in
fortnite creative
by this awesome creative team that
called themselves atlas creative
and tomorrow at 10 a.m eastern
you'll be able to go into fortnite and
you can play capture the flag in a
recreated version
of blood gulch okay it's gonna be fun
everything
is in fortnite right now so are you done
for the season
you know i mean agent jones is uh is
actually just kind of getting
warmed up so uh i think there's actually
one more thing jesus how much
oh walking dead
michonne and daryl wow
yo their bag is unlimited
everything in pop culture fortnight has
no idea where we're going next but i'm
on board
yo melville said craig is going to be
donald mustard from epic games all right
come up in a moment keanu reeves is
going to present the award for best game
direction
we've still got a few more surprises
don't go anywhere right now
let's hear from rocket league on their
new season
hey what's up this is cascade and i am
stoked to be welcomed into the rocket
oh
yeah we're back in the club that's
because it's cascade and cascade is an
amazing
dj oh oh i'm in there
yo i'm in this i mean it's just cascades
music oh
yo oh let's get it
oh you atticus rocking or we know it's
lit with attic rockets
oh it's the shoulder length you're the
back of the club couple drinks to show
the league
[Applause]
bartending let me get another one
oh man that beat his whole body karate
what's the dj what's what was it cascade
cascade
dj frank that's cascade
oh
what's going on skyrim
coming to game pass
[Music]
your next favorite game hold on
what's going on oh what's going on big k
pass commercial
skyrim's coming to gamepad yeah
bro you got to diversify your portfolio
brother it can't be hip-hop 100
all day every day now
you gotta get some cascade going on
actually that stuff i listen to the most
i
i don't the majority of the songs uh the
music i listen to
they have just completely instrumental
i don't really listen a whole lot of
like vocal
[Music]
wait did they just show discord coming
to um
[Music]
no it's already no it said it's on pc
this is a game that's commercial
right but i i i thought they said among
us coming to pc game back
no probably uh crossbow i don't know
it's a lot of games bro oh
[Music]
tell me when skyrim is man
34 launched yesterday okay
ultimate for a dollar to get people in
284 game is moving
it's moving just check pokemon go on my
phone and there's
cooper everywhere so we can officially
declare another
i gotta go to twitter to find out the
actual details so appearing in balloons
and at poke stops
and you can save shadow whooper from
their villainous clutches
make over your buddies take photos of it
with go snapchat
skyrim's coming to game pass 12 15. if
you're enjoying it
pokemon goes december i'm so glad
remember i told you i was
i was thinking about
[Music]
mobile
is
huh so i'm not going to play through
every single yakuza gaming they're all
on gamepad
said you was vibing to the music and you
didn't see the announcement
[Music]
yo we we gotta do it for the culture man
anyone in the chat
that wants to play this blood goat with
fortnite with me tomorrow hit me up man
i don't even play fortnite but for blood
goats i'm gonna do my joint
it's a big deal the cross promotion
it's a shame the gun play is doing here
at some point as it is
to be honest in 2076. yeah i mean dude
fallout 76 is turning up
a lot of content
describe of avalon free for all 76
players
you know that keeps them yeah and it's
and it's all game fast
[Music]
fast too i gotta respect nintendo
[Music]
and then the trailer was lit oh
i went crazy
the game awards is back we've got a lot
of great show keanu reeves still to come
christopher nolan and so much more and
of course we've got the game award sale
happening
so make sure to check that out across
all platforms for the next 30 minutes on
twitch
you can get a free call on twitter i'm
here to tell you all
and now they're back to give you a first
look at the gameplay from this indie
title
the first ever single-player concert did
you ever watch the avengers legends
universe
this is ruined king a league of legends
story
oh you you actually watched it i got
through most of it
this game is you watch the ending that's
all that matters is when step farther
gets reincarnated cut through
i i want to see what this game is yeah
you need to go back and watch just when
he comes back
it's only like 10 minutes long when you
live in buildings
i'll i'll find a good youtube video
oh okay
let's start the party
queen of buildings
yeah the priestess this kind of reminds
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah you mean to tell me guns could take
down callous but
okay you got that now you got that man
you got that
a man who oh no it is made by the same
people
please welcome keanu reeves
it's time to get beautiful i think you
know what's crazy
greetings i'm honored before present the
game award for
best game direction direction this
category
recognizes the studio that demonstrated
shout out to the folks at team at cd
projekt red and poland
i had an amazing experience playing
johnny silverhand in cyberpunk 2077.
jesus and now here are the nominees for
best game director all right who voted
what
best game direction no i'm looking
that's a one-time gig
when it's done we're done
i know you wish things were different
congratulations i think that's it which
why do you think that's it
because me and saul said different stuff
thank you you said
the last one you're the only one that
said last of us shout out to our game
director yes
i don't want to get gas because they
didn't three
it's an honor to be in this category
with such incredible games
um direction without a team to
internalize it
and
thanks to my foreign
[Music]
of the year presented by christopher
nolan and we'll also have a tribute to
all the nominees performed by the london
philharmonic orchestra back
at abbey road studios uh game of the
year is coming up
right now gta online best game direction
in the game ain't done it
f is the most player that's supposed to
be included savage
all right i'm gonna go ahead and find
out who won that
is this the right place for the party
can we post it because i got to find out
no but don't reveal it here cause we
want to talk about the whole summit
we're all here because of one man you're
not on the mainland now
everything goes
[Music]
i need someone to rob it you're
obviously going to need
a submarine i don't agree with that game
getting there
like i could give last of us a lot of
stuff but i don't agree with that
let's try and come up with this
[Music]
i don't actually know because i mean you
look at cyberpunk
number one most concurrently
[Music]
was born about eight million pre-orders
oh yeah flexible that's what we're doing
you're really trying aren't you and it's
intending
to be following the unexplained death of
the king
you'd be acting like that's that that's
that's their game it's in fact to
celebrate this event
[Music]
you don't want to acknowledge
[Music]
[Music]
what one gave your life
[Music]
you realize the majority of the
nominations is sony games right
so long as the last of us
those effects are still available so
keep posting to your instagram reels and
coming up we'll find out who's getting a
real life game award trophy for game of
the year
oh wow
where are you respawn the gods but this
is like a
it's like a metal bomb type oh it's oh
oh it's a no disrespect
no all the districts the things you got
no i mean listen if anybody listen one
thing i go out i never disrespect the
guards
anything they do fire so if they jump in
their face they're jumping in the arm vr
space
i hope they have like a good
announcement at the end they got to
because like they showed perfect darts
so soon like
you said and we're about to keep your
expectations
no i'm not talking about xbox i'm hoping
like nintendo's there
so yeah i won titan four three also and
gene i wouldn't be really into this if
it was on ps4 but sony can't get it
right that's a piece of traffic
you want to make a wack game yeah it was
something we had you know what i'm not
going to do
i want to know who wins always
i
we all know it's going to be a tough job
this looks good though
that's all we can ask for
beyond
talk needle that's all we can ask for
rnf he said respawn hasn't made a bad
facts
gotta respect it yo they make a white
game yet
man everyone in the chat now go get that
oculus man show her man uh build some
support
ain't moving out here welcome back to
the game awards i'm so excited about
that medal of honor
from respawn in vr surprise it's out
right now what an incredible trailer and
game i can't wait to play that
hopefully this weekend all right uh when
the show ends the games continue with
the game awards festival
you can play upcoming games
now which means no downloads on pc mac
or
phones uh make sure to check it out uh
we got playable games available all
through the weekend
all right we've got one last world
premiere to share with you
check this out oh it's nothing sony
nothing
starfield can we get a starfield though
we know now that in the early years of
the 20th century
this world was being watched
eagle houston your goal for landing over
it's clearly not god of war or horizon
yeah definitely not that
what you call it the the perfect doc
reveal is huge
mass effect mass effect
oh the remaster trilogy oh liara that's
the oh
yo
wait what that this is a new game yes
because that's homegirl you know they
live forever they're sorry race they
live for eons
i need to really play let's go these
mass effect games
okay
all right well to present our final
award this man has created some of the
most iconic films of all time
some of which screen this summer in
fortnight and on december 20th
i'll be sitting down for a conversation
with him on youtube to talk about the
home release of tenet and his
illustrious career
and if you've got questions for them
which i'm sure you do send them our way
using the hashtags
i've always been interested in telling
stories that immerse these
i like movies that unfold in unexpected
ways and pull people into a world
when i look at video games i see a lot
of parallels with that kind of
storytelling
how a player's agency and choice
intersect with
more traditional storytelling methods
it's uh exciting to see
you're right but it wasn't bad it was
terrible tonight all six nominees
are true master works in immersive
storytelling it didn't help
the london philharmonic orchestra
conducted by my old friend
lord belfie lord oh he got a lord to
conduct it
[Music]
that's our peoples it's our people oh
man this bad remake
[Music]
i want you to final fantasy so bad
that's my personal game of the year
final fantasy
and ghost is like right next to it i
hate that i still get chills
who won the best audio
[Music]
the last of us i believe
that's such a good game what the doom
wins it
[Music]
studios vibe for all let's go let's go
put your cherry blossoms up
this is time this is what we're waiting
for
[Music]
let's get your sakai masks on
let's get it loki
i would want ghosts to win it
[Music]
the reason that i can't like if last of
us doesn't win it
i would like ghost to win it because i
feel like ghost was a great new ip final
fantasy is amazing but it's still
some form of a concept that's already
been made i i hear that
it goes to the game of the year deaf i
can hear your heartbeat
[Laughter]
[Music]
how could last of us not win daniel i'm
holding out for animal crush
edible crushes blindside everybody hey
has animal crushing on anyone nope never
won anything
not even for family nope didn't even get
nominated
i don't remember animal crosses with
anything they want they cuz they got
nominated for family
[Music]
here we go the sleeper
here we go oh they won family game my
bad thank you ever cub thank you g
they won so they went family game they
did win
i think
this is it the big one oh
man twitter is the better this is about
to be messy
as animal crossing with nintendo fans
going how long they splitting on animal
crossings
you want to give
[Music]
it is when i watch grown men lose their
vibes
on twitter and now
the game of the year award here goes too
it's over it's over
clean sweet dominance
last of us too i need your knees
we need your knees and you know
i want to thank people i can't wait to
hug and high five and get drunk with
each one of them
that's gonna have to wait till next year
um
because for the most part we all voted
the same thing sony partners again scott
rhodey connie booth herrmann
pulse sean layton jim ryan yours oh i'm
so glad i went with the last man
all that slanderers
we'd like to thank our friends and
family that stood by us and supported us
throughout
uh us making this game you inspire us
to make better more meaningful games
don't hate um
i don't agree with it but it was still
phenomenal congratulations to naughty
dog
game of the year for the last of us part
two and congratulations to all our
winners
and all the nominees around the world
virtually appreciate greatness together
in person in the meantime there'll be
plenty of games to play
congratulations also to pluto who is
voted by the fans as their favorite
emerging
valor and streamer let's all go raid her
stream right now on twitter
wow post show that's coming up right now
at slash twitch gaming i'll be joining
them
phenomenally we didn't like in tonight's
show
take care absolutely stay safe happy
holidays and be well
i'm jeff keeley good night we'll see you
next year hello
game of the year deaf singer
your knees please no knees
dad's sick i need you to come to the
front of the congregation
i'm just gonna go back
another one another one down what do we
think
let's get to dutch real quick man what
do we think man overall what was your
feelings on
it
oh five out of ten yeah
nothing nothing no standouts for your
dutch no standouts
uh nice to see the initiative eventually
announced perfect dark
which is what we thought it was all
along
yes yes what do you feel about you feel
episodic all that still part of it
uh hopefully not i don't like the way
final fantasy is doing episodic
yeah um
arc 2 is a weird one that was bigger now
exclusive right xbox exclusive
even if it is exclusive the way the
engine was in the last game doesn't fill
us with any confidence
yes they need to ditch that engine and
start something new if they're going to
be doing something they look like they
ditched that injury
they look like they're doing something
special with how that was looking to you
um but other than that no it was nothing
it was nice to see eventually getting
recognition of
flight sims eventually coming to xbox i
was disappointed so when he didn't
turn up in terms of actual announcements
right i thought that would have shown
something off
considering they've got two major games
well yeah two
big sequels coming next year
apparently i still doubt that they're
both coming next year we haven't seen
anything of them
right in terms of actual gameplay
meaning the god of war the ragnarok
and the um what you call it you got the
horizon and i believe with the ratchet
yeah mm-hmm no um
but yeah other than that it was pretty
average uh
yeah cool cool so i'll just say real
quick if i pass it over
what was your ultimate highlight of the
show what really got you the most pumped
uh perfect dog i think um
okay okay big perfect dog fan no doubt
i said the direction they're going with
that game because obviously we know
perfect
if you ever played the originals or at
least hopefully most people will have
played the originals
it was a bit of a wacky game yeah it
wasn't just like a spy
like a spy splinter cell esque game it
was uh it was it was strange but this
one doesn't seem like it's going down
that direction
it's it is reinvented no doubt no doubt
man shout out to atl with the final
super chat thanks for entertaining us
this night yo much love y'all rocking
with us this whole time almost 300 in
there
shout out to our rmb you know what i'm
saying third two hours of chat perfect
dog that's all i needed king we won
okay okay so he agrees with okay
everybody liking that joint
that's what's up that's singing man
rough night at the office for you but uh
how do you feel about this show i'll
give the show a good
yeah seven at ten eight to ten
okay okay give me some uh give me
overall thoughts and then what your
ultimate standout was
mean the pacing was good there was great
reveals
of a lot of games that i'm interested in
and
some ones i didn't think were going to
be there so there was a lot of good
reveals which i'm happy with
um shout out to sony not showing
anything oh um
they had the the bike game in the um
season
season and return basically that that's
the entire show but
you know when i was promised side of
hill but i mean
and then you know it was just a ton of
good reveals i mean shame about who one
game of the year
the standard is tough because i got you
most excited give me even if it's more
than one
if you're struggling just tell me the
ones that did get you excited
all right so the new mass effect because
there's liara and then that
one dragon riding game with all the
dragons
oh we forgot about that game what the
hell was that um something desert what
was that
no no no no crimson no it wasn't crimson
desert
crimson desert was one but it was a game
before that it was
century something it was just a whole
bunch of dragons flying around shooting
each other oh yes yes yes yes yeah i
remember that one i remember that one
yeah
that game then there was of course i had
um the ruined king league legends
i had warhammer k-mate that was good
see there's too many games
bro there's a lot of games in there that
i'm actually interested in so i'm like
zero says century age of ashes that's
where the kitchen
chassis yeah yeah like it was overall a
good show because there's tons of games
i'm interested in they showed me a good
variety
i mean they showed me games i didn't
even think no existed until later
yeah overall good oh much better last
year
no doubt no doubt addict the potential
winner
of gabe crown your lord this year
dominating with a lot of
great picks but about to show itself
like how you feel about the show
and what were some of the top reveals
that got you crazy
um when it comes down to it i actually
feel like the show was solid
it was a good eight because like the
thing about it is people
go into this expecting it to be an e3
yes
and it's just like look like they give
you stuff but they don't
they it's not meant to replace an e3
it's not meant to even be a pax it's
meant to
show rewards celebrate games that came
out that year
and give you and give you uh reveals
during the show it's not meant
to have that much info and i think a lot
because i see a lot of people saying it
was bad on twitter
right and it's just like look like i get
it last year
the xbox series x was announced on it so
you know maybe that put the ceiling this
year a little bit too high
yeah but it's just like they now it's
perfect dark like what else do you want
right now
let's be real the way greeny set it up
he was trying to say like we wouldn't
expect much i don't know any bigger
i thought that was a big look i don't
think he was necessary to talk about
any one announcement when i was reading
that because i
i was seeing like some crazy stuff
people were predicting
people were going too crazy i think he
was like look like
we're going to be there but don't be
expecting a whole lot
like because because they were only
there and really like they were there
with the master chief in fortnight and
they were they were perfect dart
like they were there but i think he was
mainly like look
we're going to be there but don't expect
us there
there because of last year real quick
jonathan b follow super chat
when i saw that data dying logo at the
top of that village that i lost it top
three reveals perfect dark
callisto protocol which was callisto
that sounded that sound
what was that in three seasons callisto
protocol sound from
jonathan b remind me what type of game
that was cause i remember that name when
i was excited about whatever that game
was i just can't remember it right now i
shot it down i said
uh be honest announcement aside i was a
bit upset how they blew past someone
yeah they did blue pass yeah yeah i do
disagree with that i feel like
you know instead of having some of these
uh i understand the orchestra for the
end
uh because that's the game of the year i
have my time let's go with the death
space game
yes with homie with the thing in the
back of the neck yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're right
correct to me it's like i understand the
end
i understand talking about it in the end
right but it's just like you know the
orchestra at the end where you where you
announced game of the year that makes
sense to me
right but what i don't understand is
why you do the orchestras in the middle
and it would be okay if you did that in
the middle
if you still did the rewards how they
should be
but when jeff's up there announcing five
in a row
and it just it just feels like yo i get
it man like you know people
like you're trying to give more
announcements because that's all this is
he's trying to
market again by getting these
announcements but it's like
but you should still make sure your
foundation is built right
yeah i agree like you you like he's
sitting there like
trying to fit in like in a two-story
house fit in what it would take for an
entire apartment yeah no
and it's just it's just like yo make
sure that you do the game the awards
right
and they'll be like yo we got spots over
here we got spots over here
it feels like they're telling him where
to do it because he's having to speed
through like five awards yeah that
should normally take 20 minutes
where i agree with you is it takes away
from the winner of those awards like
they don't get a chance to really
celebrate outside of a few of them when
they did spend time i wasn't among us or
whatever
they got a lot of shine when they won
but a lot of the awards lord award
winners
you didn't get some time to even hear
from that studio yo they won all right
this one one next one this one went up
and i was like all right
they need to at least give them devs
that that i agree with that part for
real
jd game with 10 on super chat flight sim
perfect dark and game pass domination
is what this show reinforced and i'm all
about that let's get it
um see if these xbox is about to
dominate the aaa exclusive narrative
where will they go next interesting
interesting we'll continue out okay
so the yakuza collection for xbox comes
to game pass
on january 28th 2021
the game fast thing i'm announcing
skyrim's coming in the game pass
announcing all those games coming to
game pass they've been really good at
promoting game pass but it's just like
like this isn't about microsoft this
isn't about sony this isn't about
nintendo like they help make the show
what it is this is about
jeff right and it's just like you you
have an award show
but you're speeding through to show
other stuff and
that's the only that's only criticism i
have yeah at the end of the day it was
like a lot of
small stuff yeah but it's just like it's
to call the video game awards jeff
yeah but i'll be at the same time they
getting a tremendous bag
they get in the bag and i get that but
it's like to me
it it it hits the integrity of the show
in general i understand what you're
saying
back to the core of why we're here i
don't mind what they did
you know if they do this next year i i'm
still going to have the same opinion but
i understand it
like there's a difference between them
doing something i don't understand
and then doing something i understand i
get that it's like okay i don't agree
with how you're handling this
but you need the back to be doing it
so i understand why you're doing it
because i feel like
you could you could come to a better
middle ground next year
to do both that's all i have so and i
thought it was a solid show eight out of
ten i i thought they
the pacing was okay it wasn't like bad
you know there's a couple times i you
know i even went out and got something
yeah we saw but it's just like it wasn't
bad
for you but give me now your like yo
what was the joy or the announcement or
the reveal that you
lost and you're like yo this is crazy
okay so i'm gonna
this is oh i'm gonna say when last was
two one game
because it put me in the spot to win the
bend the nina i don't know if i wanted
inside of you possibly reading the bed
to crown your lord
what excited you reveal-wise well you
gotta let me get my bars off
all right get your butt it's between me
because we're the only ones that pick
last of us that many topics
i told you before that show i'm picking
last of us for everything
and you know what's funny the stuff i
lost it's the ones that i went out
that zone for like i lost the wasteland
with rpg because i said waistline it was
final fantasy
i had to go with my heart man and guess
what
my heart got that screwed up like oh my
god this is
his segment right now he hit his back
hard body i
i get less i i think i think the
sephirah thing was nice like i went back
i wasn't there live but i would have
flipped if i would have been there live
like because to me like we had the
perfect art thing was cool but i've
never really cared about perfect art
maybe they'll do what you got what they
did for you guys for god of war
with me for perfect dark so you know
we'll have to see how the game comes out
from
uh you know uh i like the fall guy stuff
i like the among us stuff i think that
that is the highlight of the show
is that that chick on screen
taking that award from among us she
started crying like yeah she was
because because that was like it hit
different for her you could tell because
it was like you know
you know you didn't see no one else
crying because that then people legitly
when they were making this game
i guarantee you they never even for one
moment thought they would ever win a
game of the year or not game of the year
but
any type of awards for the video game
awards and i think that is what stood
out
for me the most no doubt don't doubt
shout out to our and it is addict's
world okay
i i i am 100 behind that saint
i'm the mayor of addict's world and if
you don't like it you can get out
you are ridiculous anyway shout out to
rf he's i love it because the
awards are so commercialized do you feel
that heavy favorites are most likely to
win
last of us two just to keep the contrary
i don't necessarily think that i mean
you know obviously it's commercialized
but i still feel a lot of indie games a
lot of smaller games got this shine
got their love the fact that haley was
nominated in so many caves i need to go
back and watch that
yeah just so yeah overall jd gaming file
super chat did anyone peek that
hollywood is coming for yes
craven awards are full of hollywood
stars and bad robot productions that'll
make a game
do you think that's kind of an issue
like it's it was a lot of the times it
wasn't gamers up there doing stuff it
was
like it was people that i'm not saying
they're not a gamer and i get it
but it's just like come on man like you
know you could maybe because of the
pandemic
you know it wasn't a whole lot they
could do but to me
it's like i want to see more people that
are in the industry pass out these
awards
and not random celebrities but i think i
think they did a good job
of of having they did a lot of stuff for
mental health they did a lot of stuff
yeah they did they they gave future
content creators they did a lot
and not to mention they they they rated
valkyrie's stream yeah
they said they literally sent the whole
community millions of you know what's
funny
because i wanted to see her reaction
yeah that chick wasn't even streaming i
bet you she's salty right
now but she's so she she heard that
because she probably was watching it
because she wanted to see she won philly
gamers did get a vote it was a people's
choice award and a couple of
what they did they get a chance to have
specific votes but we'll get it finished
i said i said she was probably watching
that to see if she won
and then when he said let's go straight
let's go ray valkyrie stream
i bet you she writes that pc so quick
right try to get that
but look man look i thought overall was
solid i liked it a lot
you know really celebrated gaming he
listen i've never i'm not gonna sit here
act like i'm the biggest key lead fan
for everything there's things he does
sometimes that i disagree
but there's a lot of good for the
community yeah for gaming
at the end of the day this is we're at
the top of the mountains right now and
what it's showing is how much
how lucrative gaming is right now as an
industry especially remember think about
it the movie industry is in trouble
so you got that going on with covet and
then gaming was already on the rise when
movie was at his top so now it's like
people are realizing this is where it's
at you know i mean so look
overall left 4 dead reveal joint was
crazy for me
i lost my mind with the sephiroth with
the smash joint um
so many things that game what is it
crimson desert def what was the name of
that yeah that looked good
oh my god like it's very the engine
sometimes a little
but it's so ambitious dutch like what
they doing
that i was just like yo i'm pulling for
them because it's like
literally the game said what are you
liking everything in a video game
you want to ride a dragon you want to
sneak you want to be a viki like
they literally had everything you could
possibly want in a video game
and they had it rocking so yeah they
that jay looked crazy
man it was so big oh perfect dog perfect
dog that was
to be honest like i said when i'm gonna
be real with y'all when greenie said
keep your expectations low i was mad at
you i was mad
all last generation i've been told wait
so
now you know now it's time it's the new
generation
my thing is you could show something you
could tell us and i was like damn
they're not gonna do nothing
you know whatever whatever and i'm gonna
be real i was in my feelings i wasn't
expecting that this is when i said
we're talking about it we talked about
it yesterday and i didn't
talk about it too much because like i
don't really know exactly what
what's what's going on behind closed
doors like that like
because to me when he said that i didn't
see that as we're not going to be there
at all
i saw that is yo we're not announcing
some handheld
console that's going around the internet
we're not now seeing three or four games
going around the internet
what i i took it is is don't look for no
blockbuster announcement like i took it
like oh we just gonna make a couple of
game pass announcements and that's
it but when i seen purple i'm like
that's what we want we want to know
what people are working on we knew
initiative was doing something
it's a big deal you know what i'm saying
so salute to them on that
obviously the fortnight thing was crazy
but it was like one or two more games
that that really
that had me but overall man nah i liked
it i liked it had a dream
last of us did what last of us do i was
sad for ghosts i really wanted
i really felt ghost deserved but look
last of us what it is get the super chat
for me right now before the cops get
come and get me
all right let me get to it so um jd
gamer
yeah have we got any of these like i got
jonathan b
my last one i think jd gamer all these
jd gamer ones
i got the did anyone peep
you got to get that last one which is
the last one yeah that's the one
gotta find out super chat from jake and
i i gotta say because i don't get to say
these all
gotta find out super chat from jd gamer
hollywood is
devoid of new ideas and have rated comic
books novels
and are now looking to gain uh to gaming
to fill their
uh cofers or definitely butcher that
beware
of the smiling thief i agree with you jd
gamer i think that
they've stayed away from the video game
making movies because every time they do
it's
it's it's not the greatest and i think
that that what it is they're having
hollywood producers make video game
movies and the target demographic for
these
is gamers and they they watch these they
get upset
it's it's like equivalent to like comic
book games they're having
like comic book game they're having
developers making comic book movies into
a game yeah they're just showing people
get upset the realm
is crossing over on certain things and i
get it i can understand the concern i'm
not going to say jd game is out of
pocket for not being
no he's not he's not like you could be
concerned i just i think
jd like you'll see p you'll see it once
they start making a couple good ones
yeah that they're going to put more
focus and
and attention behind these and you're
going to get better ones in general from
that
we got a five dollar superchat from
jonathan b yes sir from a presentation
perspective for it to have been seamless
during your pandemics
do it to jeff for pulling that uh off i
really enjoyed it i agree
i agree like i said um there's been
times with jeff
vito but i respect what he does for the
industry and i respect that we have that
platform
that gaming awards is huge what did you
gonna say so dana said uh
the target audience for gaming movies
are not gamers
i have to disagree with you and i think
that's the reason that they'd ever do
good because they're not the target
they tried christopher how can they hit
a pop
they they try to make sure that
it's flashy and they never look back at
the actual
contents behind the movies look at this
new movie that's coming out monster
monster hunter like gamers are already
clowning on the game
look at um what was that game world
warcraft was that
was that called death singer i don't
know i actually like
the the movie uh world of warcraft
whatnot movie
but you don't think that they're trying
to target a more wider demographic
and i think that's the issue because
what they do is they do that and the the
people that they're targeting doesn't
like it
and gamers don't like it yeah no one
goes to watches but i mean like
i don't know this again i don't know the
metrics so i can't really comment on it
you know i'm saying but
i do understand where thanos is going to
some extent
but i just don't have the data to show
okay with these gaming movies
what's really going on that's what it
was i'm saying that
i actually liked what crap but you know
i'm not going to go into that too much
like i understand your point but to me
when it comes to movies they they're
designed to get as many people to watch
them as possible
and they never really look back at the
actual contents of the game
how can there's a ford vin diesel though
they got to receive all this i told her
yo i was ready to snitch i was like
there's no way that was the biggest
surprise for me
to see that game with that level of
fidelity i'm thinking it's some new
single player
amazing game and then i see the art and
addict you was onto it
because you kept saying yo it's the arc
thing on the almost
and you know what's funny you know why i
knew what that was cause i've had so
many damn times in that game
because what when you spawn like that go
like this and i'm like
that's that damn diamond yeah so when
you say and i'm like okay this looking
like a full triple a this looks like a
quadruple a production
and i'm like [ __ ] so then without when
you tell me
after we get the rules that it's exclude
microsoft and
it's going to be i guess dutch is it
exclusive to game pass without sure but
it's microsoft involvement
we know that for them to get a bag to
get this game
that looks like that they're working
with the studio yo
that's a cash and few see now i don't
have to go check the books and send the
feds over there you know what i'm saying
now i feel okay this is a legit interest
buyer who has a bag into your
little project watch a little bit i mean
arc is still getting played crazy
shout out to dizzy if i win the bend the
knee this is going to be my pose
i
but i think it's between me and king but
i i didn't look at them all because
there's a couple i missed
let's see what's up a little bit we got
to get out here we damn it three hours
dutch man first of all salute to you
brother for pulling up
you know what i'm saying last minute i
want if you're around we'll do more uh
reactions with you next time bring the
camera because you gotta be laughing
there so
of the mix up midweek mix-up podcast
out here man teleport five people where
they can find you what you got going on
man
yeah you can find us on twitter or
youtubers wondering dutch
um and again uh we had a week off after
20 episodes which yeah
you came on there last week yes uh
but uh we're back again next week with
our with a
midweek mix-up podcast and uh again
bringing
more video content uh this week as well
so looking forward to it brother keep up
the good work man love what you guys
doing salute to the team everybody you
got uh
what you got archimedes you got bob
pacha you got
yeah you got a big team man forza irwin
[Applause]
salute to the team man i love what you
guys are doing it's lit man shout out to
about your european brothers out there
and doing a thing you know what i'm
saying all i'm saying
is if i lose the vga been the knee
segment
i'm going i'm i'm going on strike what
if i still win it with a big lead even
though you guys listen
i can't wait if you want it if you win
it with the big league first thing going
with states
i want a recount i want to recap
count what did you count demand account
anyway let's not be a messy
lord that sing has been a rough night at
the office last of us
two you were not pulling for to win and
it was a clean
i know you don't like they want so many
uh awards but i'm thrilled
i'm thrilled so make sure you're gonna
be okay with your outro you know
just just breathe with me dad that's
well i'm not even mad i'm just too busy
thinking about it i bet you don't go i
bet you don't go and press start discord
for like a week
people know i don't know i knew death
was in trouble when you start giving me
the cyberpunk numbers
i mean it is what it is i mean cyberpunk
is taking up all my time so
thanks for having me always a pleasure
great show
i mean great reveals fun time
shout out to everyone who came through
yeah shout out to bulma pulled up
earlier
the king yeah who came to will to will
sweetie
gotta fight out the super chat real
quick we gotta find out super chat from
thanos
man someone told me how to pronounce
this man's name i call him dana roast
dana roast okay i'm gonna say thano
roast man is that okay with you let us
know if we got it right man
we gotta find out super chat from dana
rose say thanks for the entertainment
uh you know i i first of all i want to
appreciate everyone for coming on here
like they we we had up to like 323
people at once
like you guys love it and you know
that's why i dropped that code in the
chat because
if you guys are watching our reaction
streams you really mess with us
well thanks a little bit just everybody
pulling up having a good time but yeah
deaf man tell them real quick where they
can find you
you could find me everywhere at desinger
you ain't gonna find a mini one for a
couple weeks
well actually no you you can find me i'm
playing cyberpunk i'll be lost
premature victory lap going on with you
right now
this could be his first crown as lord
you know beating the evil sovereign who
has dominated us
for three years almost three years we've
never beat this man in predictions
you know what's it all right so all
right he said that fan heroes or
thanoros standaros okay put up
fan plus heroes or then everyone's dana
rose okay whatever
but anyway so don't forget that next
we'll forget that next week we'll
butcher your name again but uh anyway
like you could say sir we're gonna find
people find you what you got going on
man
you can find me on twitter at lord
addict iop
you can find me on youtube at gaming
addicts
you can find me on twitch gaming out of
do i never stream on
you can find me on xbox at lord attic
for a bunch of numbers
and you can find me celebrating this
sunday
at 11am man if i lose i'm gonna be very
disappointed yeah we gotta do that
number count we gotta count the votes
all the states
and then we gotta recount that we're
gonna recap uh and then you know i wanna
appreciate everyone for coming through
you guys have been salute a great
great set of people man we try to evolve
the chat as much as possible in here
and uh oh so it looks like daniel got
the far cry yeah thank you for the fun
of christ
but i definitely appreciate it for
coming through definitely come through
yes it's sunday at 11 a.m
and you're gonna see who gets crowned as
the bending
as the what are we calling this event yo
yo
kovo how you coming for my man like that
he said we could find you
interrupting the lord's decision it is
what it is
if i lose the bet you're just gonna have
to deal with it
but i definitely want to appreciate it
definitely come through there see who
gets crowned
i'm pretty sure it's gonna be attic but
you know that that's to be up
i i low key i want to go and just see
who wins
but part of me is like it's just two
days i might as well just wait
so i'm gonna wait i'm gonna see who wins
live
with everyone that's gonna do that
cognito live we are we are live
you know but i definitely appreciate it
you already know so with everybody that
pulled up today fun show long show again
everybody that came through the king
you can only stay for a little bit
because he has got to work you know i'm
saying wilhelm scream
boomstick you know what i'm saying and
of course the two
amazing people in the panel you know
what i'm saying my boy def cigar my
destiny bredrin
you know what i'm saying always talking
at xbox talk and of course wondering
dutch his first one with us
dutch i wanted more we need more from
you more reactions from you so you
always welcome brother
every time there's a reaction hit me up
bro you already know and i got a special
for the chat real quick do you guys
think the quality of our
stream was a lot better yeah we're
messing around with our zoomer stuff on
our back end yeah so yeah we got some
surprises for you guys
next year it's gonna be crazy yeah shout
out to shout out to twitch out there on
thanks for the stream i enjoyed watching
them one game more
thank you yo philly eagle thank you you
know what i'm saying salute
yo sorry it's like we said you know uh
every dime this podcast makes we put
right back into the show
uh we we got some surprises man we we're
going to shake it up a little bit we're
going to check it out
we got some fun stuff cooking here and
king has been in charge for most of it
so you know it's going to be like
anyway look that's all i got go ahead
with this outro
get everybody everybody enjoy your day
and
peace enjoy gaming man love y'all
[Music]
you